Hey guys, Ryan from Argentina here and this show really means a lot to me.
大家好，我是来自阿根廷的瑞安，这个节目对我的意义非常重大。
What you've made here is absolutely a masterpiece.
你们在这里创作的作品绝对是一部杰作。
I watch it when I'm sad, when I'm angry, when I'm happy, when I'm frustrated.
当我难过时、生气时、开心时、沮丧时，我都会看它。
I've watched it for a lot of years now.
我看了很多年了。
I'm 25.
我今年25岁。
Last year I was diagnosed with autism, so I learned that this show had also helped me make some social skills and understand social cues in a way that I didn't quite understand.
去年我被诊断出患有自闭症，所以我意识到这个节目也帮助我掌握了一些社交技巧，并以一种我以前不太懂的方式理解了社交暗示。
It scratched that itch for me and it really has helped me with a lot of relationships right now and in the past as well.
它满足了我的那种需求，而且无论是在现在还是过去，它确实在很多方面帮我处理好了各种人际关系。
It really has in some way shaped who I am as a person.
它在某种程度上确实塑造了我作为一个人的性格。
You've made something really really beautiful here once again and thank you for making this show.
你们在这里再次创作了一些非常非常美好的东西，谢谢你们制作了这个节目。
in New York City.
在纽约市。
I can't believe it, Craig, can you believe it?
我简直不敢相信，克雷格，你敢相信吗？
I can't believe it.
我简直不敢相信。
We're here.
我们到了。
Here we are at the end of season one of How I Met Your Mother episode 22, appropriately titled The End.
我们迎来了《老爸老妈浪漫史》第一季的尾声，第22集，片名非常贴切，叫做《终局》。
Welcome to the end of season one, but certainly not the end of all the way.
欢迎来到第一季的尾声，但绝不是整段旅程的终点。
We got eight more seasons to go, but welcome to How We Made Your Mother, where I, Josh Radner, who played Ted Mosby on all nine seasons of how I met your mother, and going back through the show with all these years later, with our older eyes and our wiser minds, with Craig Thomas, the co-creator of the show, along with Carter Bayes.
我们还有八季要走，不过欢迎来到《我们是如何创作老爸老妈浪漫史的》，在这里，我——乔什·拉德纳，在《老爸老妈浪漫史》全部九季中饰演泰德·莫斯比，带着多年后的阅历、更成熟的目光和更睿智的心态，与该剧的共同创作者克雷格·托马斯（另一位是卡特·贝斯）一起，重新回顾这部剧。
Hi, Craig.
嗨，克雷格。
Hello, sir.
你好，先生。
Great to see you, as always.
很高兴见到你，一如既往。
Thrilled, we've made it to the end of season one.
我们竟然走到了第一季的尾声，真是太激动了。
How's this been for you?
这对你来说感觉怎么样？
20 years later, looking back on all this, It's been a blast for me, but let's go and get into it.
20年后再回首这一切，对我来说这是一段非常美妙的经历，不过我们还是直接切入正题吧。
Point of interest, the episode's actually called come on and not the end, but the end might be a better title.
顺便提一下，这一集的真实片名其实叫《来吧》，而不是《终局》，不过《终局》也许是个更好的名字。
And I think it's on theme because we've pitched better titles for many of the episodes that we've done.
而且我觉得这很符合我们的风格，因为我们为拍过的许多剧集都想过更好的片名。
We're like, yeah, come on, come on, come on.
我们当时就会说，对啊，来吧，来吧，来吧。
It's a pretty good title.
这真的是个挺不错的片名。
It's pretty good.
挺不错的。
Come on, it works.
《来吧》，这名字行得通。
Milk was slightly controversial.
《牛奶》那一集稍微有点争议。
There were a few who were like, maybe we could've had a better title there.
有几个人觉得，也许我们当时能起个更好的名字。
Milk is the only one.
《牛奶》是唯一一个。
Maybe zip, zip, zip, and milk were the two.
也许《拉链，拉链，拉链》和《牛奶》是那两个。
Although I do think you're right, the wedding should have been called plus one.
不过我确实觉得你说得对，婚礼那一集本该叫《加一》。
Plus one.
加一。
What you learn 20 years later is call it the thing that you're going to call it 20 years later.
20年后你学到的一点就是：直接用你20年后打算叫的名字。
Call it that in the moment and that will be easier 20 years later.
当下就这么叫，20年后就会轻松得多。
Let your future self name the episodes.
让未来的自己来给剧集命名吧。
Let older wiser future you name your episodes.
让更成熟、更睿智的未来的你来为剧集命名吧。
So Alec, tell us when this aired.
那么亚历克，告诉我们这一集是什么时候播出的。
When did a season episode 22 of season one air?
第一季第22集是什么时候播出的？
It aired on May 15, 2006.
它于2006年5月15日播出。
And you, Craig, let us know.
还有你，克雷格，告诉我们一下。
Give us just a bare bones description of what happens in this episode.
用最简练的语言描述一下这一集发生了什么。
This was the description on Hulu.
这是Hulu上的剧情简介。
I think I watched a plug for How Much Mother and how to watch it in America.
我想我看过一则关于《老爸老妈浪漫史》以及如何在美国观看它的广告。
You can watch it on Hulu or Netflix.
你可以在Hulu或Netflix上观看。
And I've been jumping back and forth between the two as we go through the season.
随着我们回顾这一季，我一直在两者之间来回切换。
So that's my little plug for How To Watch How Much Mother on Hulu.
所以这就是我为如何在Hulu上观看《老爸老妈浪漫史》做的一点小广告。
This was the description of Come On.
这是《来吧》一集的简介。
And it sounds like AI wrote something wrong.
听起来就像是人工智能写错了东西。
It sounds like something glitched.
听起来像是出了什么故障。
Here's the description.
剧情简介是这样的。
episode 22, come on, Ted uses a randance to keep Robin from camping.
第22集，《来吧》，泰德用雨舞阻止罗宾去露营。
It's just like, it's like, did something glitch out there?
这感觉就像，就好像，哪里出故障了吗？
Is that it's height?
是它太高了吗？
Are there types of involved?
里面有什么错别字吗？
If you're like, oh, I've heard good things about this show.
如果你听到别人说，哦，我听说这部剧很不错。
What's this episode?
这是哪一集？
Wait, what?
等等，什么？
Ted uses a randance to keep Robin from camping.
泰德用雨舞阻止罗宾去露营。
Yeah.
对。
I guess that says it.
我想这就是它的意思。
It's true.
这是真的。
It's all true.
这都是真的。
All those words are true, but it's a weird little haiku.
所有这些词都是真的，但它读起来像个奇怪的小俳句。
It's been distilled down to there.
剧情就被提炼成了这样。
It raises more questions than it answers, as they say.
正如他们所说，它引发的问题比解答的问题还要多。
Yeah.
对。
So, so Robin's going to go camping with Sandy Rivers.
所以，罗宾要和桑迪·里弗斯去露营。
Robin's going to go camping with Sandy Rivers.
罗宾要和桑迪·里弗斯去露营。
She's learning that he is moving on from being her co-anchor.
她得知他不再担任她的联合主播了。
He's going to, he got a big job at CNN.
他要去CNN谋得一份高薪工作。
And now he's saying, hey, let's finally get together.
现在他说，嘿，我们终于可以在一起了吧。
You have a no-dating co-workers thing.
你们有个“不准和同事约会”的规定。
So there's this threat that Robin can end up with this other guy who's kind of horrible and ridiculous.
所以这就产生了一个威胁，罗宾可能会跟这个既糟糕又荒唐的其他男人在一起。
There's a little broadcast news going on here, don't you think?
这里面有点像电影《收播新闻》的感觉，你不觉得吗？
There's definitely broadcast news.
这绝对有《收播新闻》的影子。
I found myself thinking about that great movie for you young kids out there, watch the movie, broadcast news from the 80s, hilarious and heartfelt comedy.
我不禁想起年轻时的各位朋友们都看过的、那部来自80年代的伟大电影《收播新闻》，那是一部既搞笑又走心的喜剧。
And elements of this, there is the really like pretty boy newscaster guy played by William Hart very brilliantly.
而其中的某些元素，比如威廉·赫特非常出色地饰演的那个超级大帅哥新闻主播。
And does he have any substance at all?
他身上有任何内涵吗？
Is sort of the question of that movie.
这可以说是那部电影探讨的问题。
And Sander Rivers is very similar to that.
而桑迪·里弗斯跟那个角色非常相似。
So yeah, there's this thread is Robin going to go with this other guy or does Ted still have a chance with her.
所以，是的，这里有这样一条线索：罗宾是要跟这个别的男人走，还是说泰德对她仍然有机会。
and Marshall and Lily, Marshall discovers that Lily has without telling him applied to this month's long art internship in San Francisco that would interfere with their wedding, which sends their wedding and their whole relationship into an existential crisis right as Ted is also trying to kind of see if he can win Robin over before Sandy Rivers gets his chance.
还有马歇尔和莉莉，马歇尔发现莉莉在没有告诉他的情况下，申请了旧金山一个长达数月的艺术实习项目，这将会干扰他们的婚礼，从而把他们的婚礼和整段感情都推向了一场存在主义危机，而此时泰德也正试图看看自己能否在桑迪·里弗斯抢先之前赢得罗宾的芳心。
And his best way of doing that is to make it rain, to watch out, rain out the company camping trip that Metro News 1 is about to have.
而他做到这一点的最好方法就是人工降雨，注意了，就是用雨水浇灭都市新闻一台即将成行的公司露营之旅。
So yes, Hulu distilled it down to one beautiful, perfect sentence there.
所以，是的，Hulu把它浓缩成了一个优美、完美的句子。
So how's it been, how's older, why does their future Craig feeling about present day, 2005, six, Craig, who made the first season of the show?
那么感觉如何，更成熟、更睿智的未来的克雷格，对2005到2006年制作了该剧第一季的当年的克雷格作何感想？
I've loved rewatching season one.
我很喜欢重新观看第一季。
And by the way, I'm wearing my, if anyone's watching this, I'm wearing my big foot shirt in honor of martial arts in honor of our final episode of season one for the podcast.
顺便说一句，如果有人在看这个视频的话，为了向马歇尔致敬，为了向我们播客的第一季最后一集致敬，我穿着我的大脚怪衬衫。
I love this, Josh.
我太喜欢了，乔什。
It's been amazing.
这感觉太奇妙了。
I really had not rewatched the show since it ended.
自从剧集结束以来，我真的再也没有重温过它。
I had not, I had big, a couple episodes here and there, Thanksgiving, Thanksgiving, or someone, you know, someone wanted to watch this, watch that.
我没有，我只是偶尔看过一两集，比如感恩节那一集，或者有人想看这个、看那个的时候。
I've not done this, I've not gone back through and a lot of these I hadn't seen in years and years and years.
我没有这样做过，我没有从头到尾重温，其中很多集我真的已经好多年没看过。
And I'm loving it, some of it plays very different, three, 20 years older eyes and other parts of it.
我很喜欢这种感觉，带着年长20岁的目光去看，有些部分的感觉大不相同，而另一些部分。
I'm just right back in that moment.
我又一下子回到了那个时刻。
And I can remember it precisely what that moment felt like.
我能精确地记起当时那种感觉是怎样的。
What about you?
你呢？
Well, you know, someone told me, I don't remember who it was, but if someone on the show said, during first season, we're gonna look back on these and it's gonna look pretty raw, pretty, like we are finding our footing, we are finding our vibe, our voice, all that.
嗯，你知道的，有人跟我说过——我不记得是谁了，但剧组里有人在第一季的时候说过，我们以后回过头来看这些会觉得挺粗糙的，挺像我们在摸索方向、寻找自己的基调、声音以及所有这一切的。
And I think on some level that's true, you look back and you say, oh, we figured out how to do this better or this better, but I was startled at how fully formed the show was from the jump.
我觉得从某种程度上讲这是真的，你回过头看会说，哦，我们当时懂得了怎么把这个或者那个拍得更好，但我还是被这部剧从一开始就展现出的成熟度给震惊到了。
Like the show gets funnier, the stakes get higher, the characters deepen, we figured a lot of stuff out.
比如节目变得越来越有趣，赌注越来越高，角色更加立体，我们摸索出了很多门道。
You figured out how to mine more comedy, like you figured out more comedy for Robin, different comedic tracks for Ted that weren't there in the first season.
你们摸索出了如何挖掘更多喜剧效果，比如为罗宾创造了更多笑料，为泰德设计了第一季中没有的不同喜剧路线。
But I was surprised at how many bangers are in first season.
但我惊讶于第一季里竟然有那么多精彩绝伦的亮点。
Like there's some classic episodes in first season.
比如第一季里有一些非常经典的剧集。
And I think that if you watch all 22 episodes, I understand some more of the like stickiness of the show.
而且我认为如果你看完所有22集，我能更理解这部剧那种让人欲罢不能的粘性。
Like there was that episode where Jordana turned to me and she was like, I'm in.
就像乔丹娜转过身对我说的那集一样，她说：“我入坑了。”
Like I'm emotionally invested in these characters.
就像我对这些角色产生了情感投入。
I wanna figure this out.
我想弄清楚这一切。
I wanna keep journeying with these people.
我想继续和这些人一起经历这段旅程。
And I think for a first episode of the first season of a television show, it did exactly literally what a TV show is supposed to do.
我认为对于一部电视剧的第一季的第一集来说，它完美地做到了电视剧应该做的事情。
It weaseled its way under your heart.
它悄悄钻进了你的心坎里。
It tickles your funny bone.
它触动了你的笑神经。
it makes you wanna spend at least 22 minutes a week with these people who are now a lot more than that if you can watch it at your own pace.
它让你每周至少愿意花22分钟和这些人在一起，如果你按自己的节奏观看，时间甚至会远远不止这些。
But I think it was like, I'm startled at how successful it was just in the basics of what a first season of television is supposed to do.
但我当时想的是，它在完成电视剧第一季本该做到的基础工作时，能取得如此成功，这让我大吃一惊。
Yeah, I'm so glad it still feels that way.
是的，我很高兴它现在感觉依然如此。
I, similarly, I'm impressed by what we could cram into 22 minutes.
同样地，我对我们在22分钟里能塞进那么多内容感到印象深刻。
Is that there's some of these episodes, including the one we're gonna talk about today, come on the season family where I'm like, I can't believe how much is in there.
其中有些剧集，包括我们今天要谈论的这一集，也就是我们这季要聊的这一集，让我觉得：“天哪，我简直不敢相信里面有这么多内容。”
In 22 minutes, I mean, every single episode, I wish was 34 minutes or 45 minutes.
在22分钟里，我是说，我希望每一集都有34分钟或45分钟。
Every episode, I'd say that's the hardest thing to watch is just to rewatch it and go, oh, so many of those I would have loved who have been a little longer.
每一集都是如此，我常说最难受的就是重温的时候心想：“哦，这里面有好多内容，如果能再长一点就好了。”
But given that parameter, 22 minutes on the nose, basically, that's what a half hour has become.
但考虑到这个限制，基本上就是正正好22分钟，这也是现在半小时节目的标准长度。
My wife and I are rewatching MASH from the 1970s and they're like 25, 26 minutes long.
我和我妻子正在重温20世纪70年代的《陆军流动医院》，它们大概有25、26分钟长。
And every time I see that time code come up that says that, I'm like, I would have killed for those extras for your four minutes, the huge three or four minutes.
每次我看到时间码显示那个长度时，我都想，为了那多出来的四分钟、那宝贵的整整三四分钟，我愿意付出一切。
But that said, there is also, there's creativity, right, and necessities, the mother of invention, and you make the container the size that it is, and you say it has to fit in this container, there is invention and creativity that comes out of that.
话虽如此，这里面也有创造力，对吧，穷则思变，你把容器做成固定的大小，然后说它必须塞进这个容器里，由此会产生发明创造和无限创意。
I'm very impressed by the daring of how much we crammed into that 22-minute container, all of us.
我非常赞赏我们所有人那种敢想敢干的魄力，竟然把那么多内容硬塞进了那个22分钟的容器里。
You can see as the series goes on, you know how we've kind of been tracking, You know, I think the first time we really noticed you guys leaning into, oh, it's a narrator and he's telling the story and he can forget a detail, you know, Marshall's crown in okay awesome.
随着剧集的推进，你可以看到，正如我们之前所探讨的那样，你知道的，我想我们第一次真正注意到你们开始倾向于这种设定——哦，这里有个旁白，他在讲故事，而且他可能会漏掉一个细节，你知道的，比如马歇尔在《完全棒极了》里面的皇冠。
Like, oh, oh, I forgot.
就像是：“哦，哦，我忘了。”
There was a there's a detail.
“这里有一个细节。”
I forgot to tell you.
“我忘记告诉你们了。”
Right?
对吧？
Or, you know, there's just these different things where you guys really leaned into the narrator because think about it, if you're telling your friends a story, but one of them has to go in 12 minutes, you'll tell the story in 12 minutes.
或者，你知道的，就是有这些不同的地方，你们真正开始依赖旁白这个设定，因为仔细想想，如果你在给朋友讲一个故事，但其中一个人12分钟后就得离开，你就会在12分钟内把故事讲完。
like, you'll figure out a way to compress the story to get it told.
你会想办法压缩故事把它讲完。
And I think that, yeah, 25 minutes would have been great.
我想，是的，25分钟当然会很棒。
There would have been some, but also you might have looked back and said, wow, we could have taken three minutes out of that episode.
可能会有一些额外的内容，但反过来你可能也会回过头来说：“哇，我们其实可以从那一集里剪掉三分钟。”
Like, I think there's something, I think I mentioned this, but Leonard Bernstein said, you know, what are the necessary ingredients to create a work of genius?
就像我觉得，我好像提到过这个，伦纳德·伯恩斯坦曾说过，创造一部天才之作的必要元素是什么？
You need a great idea and not quite enough time.
你需要一个伟大的创意，外加一点点不够用的时间。
And we didn't have quite enough time, right?
而我们当时确实没有足够的时间，对吧？
like it forced us into some very interesting narrative, daring narrative choices that, you know, you look back and again, it's an imperfect, perfect process.
这迫使我们做出了一些非常有趣的叙事选择、很大胆的叙事选择，你回过头来看，这又是一个不完美的完美过程。
It was an imperfect, perfect show or a perfectly imperfect show.
它是一部不完美的完美剧集，或者说是一部完美的不完美剧集。
And I think like you look back, I'm looking back not just at my performance but the whole show as a kind of warts and all lovable thing, you know, that you much like a, you know, like a child or someone you love, you love not because you love in spite of.
我想当你回看时，我不仅是在回顾我的表演，而是在回顾整部剧，带着一种“瑕不掩瑜”的可爱感，你知道的，就像对一个孩子或你爱的人那样，你爱他们不是因为完美，而是不计缺点地去爱。
You love all of it.
你爱他们的全部。
And I wrote you this little ditty to send to you in New York City.
我为你写了这首小曲，要发到纽约市去给你。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
Hey, I'm Carl Radke.
嘿，我是卡尔·拉德克。
You might know me from Bravo's Summer House, but on my podcast, More Life, I get your favorite reality stars off the clock and into the conversations you don't usually get to hear.
你可能从 Bravo 的《夏日山庄》里认识我，但在我的播客《更多生活》（More Life）中，我会让你们喜爱的真人秀明星们下班放松，开启那些你平时听不到的对话。
the deep stuff, the vulnerable stuff, the uncomfortable stuff.
那些深刻的内容、脆弱的心事、让人局促不安的话题。
I've sat down with Sierra Miller, Derinda Medley, Tom Schwartz, Lindsey Hubbard, and a whole lot more.
我曾与席亚拉·米勒、多琳达·梅德利、汤姆·施瓦茨、林赛·哈勃等等许多人坐在一起畅谈。
We get into relationships, growing up, the messy stuff, and everything that happens when the cameras aren't rolling.
我们探讨人际关系、成长经历、那些剪不断理还乱的麻烦事，以及摄像机关机后发生的一切。
New episodes of More Life every week, listen wherever you get your podcasts, or watch on YouTube.
每周都有《更多生活》的新节目上线，无论你在哪里听播客都可以收听，或者在YouTube上观看。
And now, back to the show.
现在，让我们回到节目中。
I think I've been avoiding rewatching it sometimes, thinking I'll be harsh on it, I'll judge it, see where there could have been better jokes.
我想我有时一直在逃避重温这部剧，以为自己会对它很苛刻，会去评判它，看看哪些地方本可以有更好的笑话。
In fact, joke, we never beat in that scene, that blow to that scene, the ending of a scene that I always thought could have been better.
事实上，有些笑料，我们在那一场戏里从未真正攻克，那个让整场戏戛然而止的包袱，也就是一场戏的结尾，我一直觉得本可以处理得更好。
It's going to bother me from 15 years ago, and it just fucking doesn't.
这件事本该让我这个15年前的人耿耿于怀，但它他妈的根本没有。
It's so interesting that you go back and there's so much more generosity.
很有意思的是，当你回过头来看时，你会带着多得多的宽容。
I have such a better ability to see the energy of the thing, the beating heart of the thing, the essential important core of what it is, and any little details, it could have been a little bit this way or a little bit more that way.
我有了更强能力去看到整部作品的能量、它的跳动的心脏、它最本质最重要的核心，至于任何微小的细节——本可以稍微这样处理，或者稍微那样调整。
They just kind of come out in the wash and the thing is the thing and I'm really proud of how the soul of it is there and I think that has transcended any go-backy nitpickiness that I thought I would have.
这些都在随后的重温中烟消云散了，作品本身就是它原本的样子，我真的为它灵魂的内核得以保留而感到骄傲，我认为这已经超越了我原本以为自己会有的那种挑刺心态。
It's so much about the energy and I think your energy in that performance of TED in season one is such a live liar.
这很大程度上关乎能量，我认为你在第一季中对泰德的演绎所展现出的能量，简直像一根点燃的引信。
There's such a drive to TED and especially in this episode, come on where Ted literally makes it rain, literally has a supernatural power to make it rain in this episode.
泰德身上有一种强烈的驱动力，尤其是在这一集里，在《来吧》这一集里，泰德字面意义上地呼风唤雨，字面意义上拥有了在这一集里让雨停下来的超自然力量。
There's something that I thought that really celebrated what Ted's energy has been through the whole thing.
我觉得这里面有一些内容，真正赞颂了泰德贯穿始终的那种能量。
And everyone, it's just their energy is coming through.
而且每个人，他们的能量都全然展现了出来。
It was such a great cast.
这是一支出色的演员阵容。
You guys were so great.
你们太棒了。
You were great together.
你们在一起的化学反应太棒了。
You were great when you were featured when it was a little more of a Ted episode or a little more of a Lillie episode.
无论是由你主导、偏向泰德视角的剧集，还是偏向莉莉视角的剧集，你们的表演都非常精彩。
We were talking about the last couple episodes of this season where Lillie kind of spiraling out and has this totally new kind of slaving unhinged energy.
我们一直在谈论这一季的最后几集，莉莉情绪有点失控，展现出了一种完全崭新的、近乎疯狂和崩溃的能量。
Just getting to see what everybody can do episode to episode and you see us all as writers and as actors discovering what we can do and what it can be and figuring out these moves.
看着大家在一集又一集中展现各自的本领，看着我们所有身为主创和演员的人去探索我们能做到什么、作品能呈现出什么样貌，并摸索出这些表演的门道。
And there's a real joy and curiosity and spark to that because you're watching people.
这其中有一种真正的喜悦、好奇心和火花，因为你在看着人们不断成长。
It's like the part of the superhero movie where the superhero is discovering their powers.
这就像超级英雄电影里超级英雄正在发掘自己超能力的那一部分。
Oh, I can do this.
“哦，我能做到这个。”
I can fly.
“我会飞。”
I can shoot lasers out of my eyes, it's that.
“我的眼睛能发射激光，”就是那种感觉。
It's like, it's finding those.
就像是，在寻找这些能力。
You're watching the show find it, find itself, find it's power.
你在看着这部剧寻找它自己，寻找它自己的定位，寻找它自己的力量。
And then as the show goes, all of those tricks, like the expanded toolbox that you discovered in season one, you bring all that into season two.
然后随着剧集的推进，所有这些技巧，比如你在第一季中发掘出的不断扩展的工具箱，你把所有这些都带入了第二季。
And you know, oh, we can go to telepathy.
你知道，“哦，我们可以用读心术。”
That's a well we can go to.
那是我们可以信手拈来的招式。
That's a kind of move.
那是某种表演手段。
We can compress time by having the narrator do something that will actually be really funny and sharp and say something about memory, say something about storytelling, say something about a father trying to print.
我们可以通过让旁白做一些既非常搞笑犀利、又能反映记忆本质、讲述故事的真谛、甚至展现一个父亲试图向……吐露心声的事情来压缩时间。
You know, I don't think he did it as much in season one, but the knowledge that he's telling what like a 16 year old and a 14 year old, these stories, I don't know how old they were supposed to be, but that kind of like, we had sandwiches.
你知道，我觉得他在第一季里没怎么这样做，但他明知自己是在向一个16岁和一个14岁的孩子讲这些故事——我不知道他们当时设定应该是多大，但那种感觉就像是，“我们当时在吃三明治。”
That's what we were doing was eating sandwiches, you know, protecting their young ears from these things.
我们当时在做的事就是吃三明治，你知道的，这是为了保护他们年幼的耳朵免受那些事情的污染。
Yeah, it just occurred to me and I'm jumping way ahead, but I just want to remember to say this.
是的，我刚刚突然想到，虽然我有点跳跃得太远了，但我只是想记住把这个说出来。
The phrase, come on, was something that had been, you know, littered throughout the show, but Ted said it a lot in a kind of like, come on, you know, like, come on, a very casual like, join me in my, join me over here.
“来吧”（Come on）这个短语，在剧中可以说是随处可见，但泰德经常用它来表达一种类似“得了吧，你知道的”，比如“来吧，加入我的行列，到我这边来。”
Just just step over here.
“就往这边走一步。”
Come But, in this episode, he is shouting to the cosmos, come on, give me what I need, right?
“来吧……”但是，在这集里，他是对着苍穹在大喊：“来吧，把我要的东西给我，好吗？”
It's so much less of a seduction and more of a demand.
这与其说是一种诱导，不如说是一种强烈索取。
I remember I had a meditation teacher who said, if you read great prayerful people, they never are delicate with the Lord.
我记得我曾有一位冥想老师说过，如果你阅读那些伟大的祈祷者的文字，他们在面对上天时从不小心翼翼。
They never say, oh, it's not too much trouble.
他们从不说：“哦，这应该不算太麻烦吧？”
Could you please slay my enemies and could you please deliver my people?
“您能不能大发慈悲消灭我的敌人，顺便拯救我的子民？”
No, if you're busy, I understand.
“不，如果您很忙的话，我完全理解。”
If you read the Psalms of David, if you read the prophets, there's an almost like ordering slay my enemies, you know, deliver my people.
如果你读《大卫诗篇》，如果你读先知们的文字，那里面几乎是一种命令式的语气——“消灭我的敌人”，你知道的，“拯救我的子民”。
Like you'd be very clear with divinity, what you need.
就像你要向神明非常明确地表达你需要什么一样。
And I think the reason the rain dance works is because Ted, it's almost like the cosmos recognize like a pure request.
我认为祈雨舞之所以管用，是因为泰德的诉求，几乎就像是苍穹识别出这是一种纯粹的请求。
They're like, we're gonna give this one to him.
它们会觉得：“我们把这个满足他吧。”
Like he needs this.
“他需要这个。”
He wants this.
“他渴望这个。”
He's earned this one.
“他配得上这个。”
Yeah.
是的。
And I loved, and I know this is jumping to the end, but I loved, I had forgotten the euphoria and the joy at that right, what that rain means to Ted.
我特别喜欢——我知道这话题跳到了结尾，但我真的很喜欢，我差点忘了那种狂喜，以及那种雨对泰德来说意味着什么的快乐。
And how just every raindrop that he gets pelted with is just the universe is on my side, the universe wants this to happen.
每一个打在他身上的雨滴都在诉说：宇宙正站在我这边，宇宙希望这件事发生。
I am receiving a blessing.
我正在接受神的赐福。
And there is something not to get to theological about it, but it's how my mind works.
这里面有些东西，虽然不想把它弄得太神学化，但这就是我脑子运转的方式。
There is something baptismal and renewing about the rain.
雨有一种洗礼和让人焕然一新的感觉。
There's something holy about the rain or the flood or the washing away of the old and the the the birthing and the welcoming of the new.
雨水、洪水、洗去陈旧、孕育并迎接新生，这些都带有一种神圣感。
That final moment with an errandary said everything had changed and rain is changed.
那个讲述一切都已改变的结局时刻，雨也随之改变了。
Water is changed.
水改变了。
It's a baptism, but it also washes some things away.
这是一场洗礼，但它也冲走了一些东西。
And Marshall and Millie are a little bit washed away by this flood.
马歇尔和莉莉也被这场洪水冲走了一部分。
In this moment, as Ted is sort of reborn into this whole new chapter and the idea of a chapter ending in a way that is sad for Marshall and a chapter beginning that is euphoric for Ted.
在这个时刻，泰德仿佛重生到了一个全新的篇章，而对马歇尔来说，一个篇章的结束带着悲伤，对泰德来说，一个篇章的开始则是狂喜的。
Oh my God, your performance and that was so wonderful, Josh.
天哪，乔治，你在那场戏里的表演太棒了。
Those two paths kind of crossing as one kind of trends up and one trends down.
这两条轨迹交织在一起，一条呈上升趋势，另一条呈下降趋势。
That is one of my favorite moments of of season one and maybe of the entire series.
那是第一季中最让我喜欢的时刻之一，也许也是整部剧中最喜欢的时刻之一。
Alec?
亚历克？
Well, I'll just use the word earn, and that was exactly what I was gonna ask you about that I felt like you earned this bit of magic, this bit of miracle through the 21 episodes that came before it.
嗯，我只想用“赢得”这个词，这也是我正想问你的，我觉得通过前面21集的铺垫，你赢得了这丝魔法，赢得了这个奇迹。
You already broke some rules as Ted did by saying I love you on the first date and the first episode.
你已经打破了一些规则，就像泰德在第一集的第一次约会时就说我爱你那样。
But then you got all the way to and now I can make it rain, which of course would not have worked in the first episode.
但接着你一路走来，现在你能呼风唤雨了，这在第一集里当然是行不通的。
That would have been what show am I watching, that this can happen.
那样的话大家就会想我到底在看什么剧，这种事居然能发生。
But whether it's the telepathy or the jumping out of the window that doesn't there or the I don't remember, all these things built up to this moment where, okay, now you have all of this, you've built this up, you've earned this, what are you gonna do with it?
但不管是心灵感应还是跳窗户，不管有没有发生，或者我不记得了，所有这些事情都铺垫到了这一刻，好吧，现在你拥有了这一切，你做好了铺垫，你赢得了这一切，你打算怎么用它？
And you just did something huge, and something huge for the character, for the characters and for the story going forward in this moment that you've reached the finale of season one, and now you can do something like this.
你刚刚做了一件大事，对于这个角色、这些人物以及故事的发展来说都是一件大事，此时你迎来了第一季的尾声，现在你可以做出这样的举动了。
Yeah, yeah, I wrote down in my little notes for this episode, I wrote, Ted is entertainingly crazy here.
对，对，我在为这一集写的简短笔记里写道，泰德在这里疯狂得很有趣。
He's one of the notes I wrote down.
这是我写下的笔记之一。
Because he's like, he really is, there is this kind of euphoric, like it is its magic, right?
因为他确实如此，有一种狂喜的感觉，就像它是魔法一样，对吧？
He's conjuring up magic on a rooftop in the middle of a storm.
他在暴风雨中的屋顶上施展魔法。
I mean, it really, and the energy Josh you had in that whole sequence.
我是说，真的，还有乔治你在整个序列中展现出的能量。
And when it started to rain and the joy and the freedom, like how did that feel acting that whole sequence?
当雨开始下的时候，那种喜悦和释放，演完整段戏是什么感觉？
Because I sensed you, I think you're doing amazing work through that whole last couple minutes of that.
因为我能感觉到你，我觉得在最后那几分钟里，你的表现真的太棒了。
There's something really shifted in you and energetically there that was wonderful.
你身上真的有什么东西转变了，那种能量非常棒。
Well, I can answer that, but I do wanna say, I find it amazing that Barney is the one on the roof with him saying, you're an idiot, what are you doing?
嗯，我可以回答这个问题，但我必须说，我觉得很有意思的是，巴尼竟然是那个陪他在屋顶上对他说“你是个神经病，你在干什么”的人。
But Barney's a magician.
但巴尼是个魔术师。
like Barney's really into magic, but he's into sleight of hand.
比如巴尼真的很喜欢魔术，但他喜欢的是手法魔术。
He's into being the god of his trip, right?
他喜欢成为自己世界的主宰，对吧？
Like he's the one kind of tricking people and stunning people.
就像他是那种捉弄别人、惊艳别人的人。
Ted is actually invoking a kind of like cosmic magic trick.
而泰德实际上是在召唤一种宇宙级的魔术。
He's petitioning something much bigger than himself.
他在向比自己宏大得多的存在祈求。
But the things, if you look back, and again, someone could write a college paper, paper on this, or ask C.P.T.
但如果你回过头来看——再说一次，有人可能会为此写一篇大学论文，或者让ChatGPT帮他们写一篇大学论文，但你知道的，孩子们别这么做。
to write a college paper on this for them, but you know, don't do that, kids.
别那么做。
Don't do that.
But what I'm saying, I think that one of the things about how we make it, whether it's a recognizable university, it honors Newtonian laws, but every once in a while, it dips into this quantum magical cosmic zone where magic exists, where literal magic exists, a rain dance, he made it rain.
但我想说的是，关于我们如何创造它，无论是符合牛顿定律的、为人所熟知的大学物理，还是偶尔涉足魔法存在的量子魔术宇宙，字面意义上的魔法，求雨舞，他真的求来了雨。
And I think there's something sweet about him telling his kids, you know, there's that Einstein quote, like you just have to decide if this is a friendly universe or not, right?
我觉得有一点很温馨，那就是他对他的孩子们说，你知道，爱因斯坦有那样一句名言：你只需要决定这究竟是一个友善的宇宙还是不友善的宇宙，对吧？
And Jordana has talked about like that's the role, especially of the mother in the early years, that her face should reflect, this is a friendly universe, like you're wanted here, you're loved, this is friendly.
约尔达娜曾谈到过，这正是母亲在孩子早年扮演的角色，她的面部表情应该反映出：这是一个友善的宇宙，这里欢迎你，你被爱着，这一切都是友善的。
But I think in some ways, Ted is also trying to give his kids the gift of it's a magical universe.
但我认为在某种程度上，泰德也是在给他的孩子们一份礼物，让他们相信这是一个充满魔法的宇宙。
There's magic in the universe.
宇宙中存在着魔法。
If your belief is strong enough, if your intention is pure, if you're aligned.
如果你的信念足够坚定，如果你的意图纯粹，如果你与之同频。
There's magic, you know?
你知道的，魔法是存在的。
What did it feel like to act to that?
演这场戏是什么感觉？
Just that ending sequence where like it works, it rains and the euphoria and the abandon, the kind of joyful abandon, and they're very confident.
仅仅是那个结局序列，它成功了，下雨了，那种狂喜与纵情，那种欢乐的纵情，他们非常自信。
It's very crazy, but it's very confidently crazy.
这非常疯狂，但却是一种充满自信的疯狂。
It's a great energy you hit there.
你当时迸发出的能量太棒了。
What did that feel like?
那是什么感觉？
I remember, I think Carter, like with smiling on set one day and he had just come from either maybe breaking the story, or he knew I was about to read it, and he said, Ted's going to do a rain dance.
我记得，好像卡特有一天在片场笑得很开心，他刚刚把这个剧情构思出来，或者他知道我快要读到这一集了，他对我说：“泰德要跳求雨舞了。”
He's going to make it rain.
“他要让天上下雨。”
And I just remember going, awesome.
我只记得当时反应是：太棒了。
How cool.
太酷了。
This is exactly the perfect Ted.
这正是最完美的泰德。
Yeah, this is perfect.
是的，这太完美了。
And he was so excited at that twist, and I was very interested in magical Ted Mosby.
他对这个反转感到无比兴奋，我也对富有魔法色彩的泰德·莫斯比非常感兴趣。
That was my favorite Ted, was like the one who could control the elements and it wasn't that he controlled them because he actually knew how to do invocations and magic.
那是我最喜欢的泰德，那个能够控制自然元素的人，这倒不是因为他真的懂什么召唤术和魔法。
He did it because it was sheer force of will, you know, and I think that there's that great quote that says, you know, once you truly decide, Providence rises up to support you.
他做到这一点是因为纯粹的意志力，你知道的，我觉得有一句名言说得很好：一旦你真正下了决心，上天就会起来支持你。
Like once the decision is fully made, divinity or Providence is on your side.
就像一旦决定彻底做出，神明或上天就会站在你这边。
And I feel like, I mean, how crazy to be on CBS in prime time and get to kind of act that out.
我觉得，在CBS黄金时段能把这种情节演出来，是多么疯狂的一件事啊。
I just knew that it was cool and I knew that it was cool in the same way that I was very interested in esoteric spirituality, not as interested as I got into it.
我只知道这很酷，而且我知道这很酷，就像我对秘传灵性很感兴趣一样，虽然没有后来那么着迷。
But I was a meditator, I was interested in what's beyond the unseen, you know, what's behind the veil.
但我当时在练习冥想，我对看不见的世界背后有什么很感兴趣，你知道的，面纱后面是什么。
I've always been curious about that.
我对这些一直都很好奇。
And I thought that was something when people say, how are you like Ted?
当人们问我“你哪里像泰德”时，我会觉得，嗯，我相信一个充满魔法的宇宙。
I'll be like, well, I believe in a magical universe.
我是说我确实相信，你知道的，我很享受剧中那些变得充满魔法和诡异的时刻。
Like I do, you know, and I enjoy the moments when the show got magical and weird.
我觉得那是《老爸老妈浪漫史》中最让我喜爱的几个瞬间。
I thought it was like there's some of my favorite how I met your mother moments.
当然，泰德也经常被重力拉回地面。
And certainly Ted was pulled down by gravity a lot.
当他落回地面时，他也是这么想的。
And he thought it when he came back down.
但每次他总是拍拍灰尘。
But he always dusted himself off.
重新跳起舞来。
and danced again.
I remember working with the choreographer who I think was Barney's cousin.
我记得曾和那位编舞合作过，我想她好像是巴尼的表妹。
Oh yeah, right.
哦对，没错。
It was her again.
又是她。
It was from, okay, I also, right?
是来自，好吧，我也，对吧？
I forgot that she came back around.
我忘了她又回来了。
That's okay, yeah.
没关系，是的。
I do remember we landed on moves that kind of like felt good in my body.
我确实记得我们最终确定了一些动作，让我身体感觉很舒服。
And moves that were both felt like could be plausible as moves he would land on, but we're also funny and joyful to do.
这些动作既符合他会做出的合理举动，同时做起来又滑稽又快乐。
I remember fingertips and that kind of like, almost like a running man, like I was hopping from foot to foot and going in circles.
我记得手指的动作，还有那种，几乎就像是在跳奔跑人舞（Running Man），我双脚交替跳跃，转着圈。
And it was like, it was ludicrous on some level, but the fact that it works makes it great, you know?
从某种程度上讲这很荒谬，但它确实管用，这就让它变得很棒，你知道吗？
Like, and I don't know if it's the dance that works or his howl towards the heavens, is demand that it rained.
而且我不知道起作用的究竟是那段舞蹈，还是他对着天空的怒吼，是他对下雨的强烈要求。
But I just feel like in that moment, like heaven smiles on him, the disguise open up for him, you know?
但我只觉得在那个时刻，上天向他微笑，天空为他敞开，你知道的？
He, what was the thing?
他，那是怎么说的来着？
Someone, I heard once someone said about astrology at a certain level of consciousness that stars control you, but at a higher level of consciousness, you control the stars.
我曾经听人说过，关于某种意识层面的占星术：在一定的意识水平下，星星控制着你；但在更高的意识水平下，你控制着星星。
Yeah, it's a great line.
是的，这是一句很棒的台词。
And I think in that moment for whatever reason, he just, he seizes control of the elements through his enormous heart and his enormous will.
我想在那一刻，不管出于什么原因，他凭借自己博大的胸怀和坚定的意志，夺取了对自然元素的控制权。
And it doesn't always work because he's often foiled pretty spectacularly by the elements and by, you know, reality, just not agreeing with him.
事情并不总是如他所愿，因为他经常被自然元素和残酷的现实相当戏剧性地泼冷水，现实就是不买他的账。
But in this moment, it works.
但在这一个时刻，它成功了。
And I always found it to be completely charming.
我一直觉得这极其迷人。
It's like, everybody has something in their life story or many things that in retrospect seem magical or seem impossible, seem improbable.
就像每个人的人生故事中都有那么一些东西，或者有很多东西，回想起来显得充满魔幻，或者显得不可能、不可思议。
And I think the magic is made in the storytelling, right?
我想魔法是在讲故事的过程中创造出来的，对吧？
Maybe it just rained.
也许只是下雨了。
Maybe it just happened to rain at that moment.
也许当时恰好就下雨了。
But in Future Ted's story, he made it rain.
但在未来泰德的故事里，是他求来了雨。
And who's right?
谁才是对的？
Did it just rain or did Ted make it rain?
究竟只是下雨了，还是泰德求来了雨？
Yeah.
对。
The answer is yes.
答案是肯定的。
Right?
对吧？
And it's like the storytelling is what makes it magic.
而且可以说，正是这种讲故事的方式让它变得如此神奇。
The way we shape our story is what is magic.
我们塑造故事的方式才是神奇所在。
The telling of the story itself is magic, especially when you're trying to tell your kids who you were and what your life was before they existed and what your heart was like and what you put out into the universe and what you got back.
讲述故事本身就是一种魔力，尤其是当你试图告诉你的孩子，在他们出生前你是谁，你的生活是怎样的，你的内心曾是怎样的，你向宇宙付出了什么，又得到了什么。
It's so pure, Ted is so pure of heart in 2006 when this is happening and the act of telling his kids, the story is also in its own way very pure of heart and I believe that magic comes from that.
它是如此纯粹，2006年事情发生时，泰德的内心是如此纯粹，而他给孩子们讲故事的行为，某种程度上也极其纯粹，我相信这种魔力就来源于此。
Yeah.
是的。
And it's also like we become so dead into the miraculousness of the every day because we live in it every single day.
而且这就好像，我们对日常生活的奇迹感变得极其麻木，因为我们每天都身处其中。
But if you were just dropped in here and you saw like trees and dolphins and ocean and constellations and like, it's a stuff, if you were like, that's how you make other humans, like it's so unbelievably miraculous.
但如果你被空投到这里，看到树木、海豚、海洋、星座，以及这一切，如果你心想，人类就是这样被创造出来的，这简直是不可思议的奇迹。
Or what's that term, the pathetic fallacy?
或者那个叫什么来着，移情谬误？
Do you know that literary term where it's raining outside and you think that it's reflective of your depressive state, but it's just, it's almost like a misassociation.
你知道那个文学术语吗？就是外面在下雨，你觉得那是你抑郁状态的映射，但其实它只是，这几乎就像是一种错误的联想。
But I believe in it.
但我相信这一点。
I feel like, yeah, some days you feel blue and the weather reflects that and it's just for you.
我觉得，是的，有时你感到沮丧，而天气恰好反映了这一点，而且它就像是专门为你准备的一样。
It's okay, I don't think that's narcissistic or whatever.
没关系，我不觉得这有什么自恋之类的。
But do you know the famous David Foster Wallace graduation speech that he gave at Kenyon, which is commonly called This Is Water?
但你知道大卫·福斯特·华莱士在凯恩那所大学发表的著名毕业演讲吗？通常被称为《这是水》。
He tells that story of there's two men talking and they're talking about whether God is real.
他讲了这样一个故事：有两个人在一起聊天，讨论上帝是否真实存在。
And the non-believer says, I was lost in, I don't know, Alaska or the Arctic and I was stranded in a snowstorm and there were no humans around and I was sure I was gonna die and I cried out.
那个不信神的人说，我当时在，我不知道，阿拉斯加或者北极，我被困在暴风雪中，周围没有一个人，我确信自己死定了，于是我大声呼喊。
I said, God, if you exist, save me.
我说：“上帝，如果你存在，救救我吧。”
And then the believer looks at him and says, well, you're here, so clearly you were saved.
然后那个信神的人看着他说：“嗯，你现在还活着，所以显然你得救了。”
And he goes, no, it wasn't God.
而他说：“不，那不是上帝。”
There was just some Eskimos started to wander by and they saved me.
只是刚好有几个爱斯基摩人路过，他们救了我。
So it wasn't God, right?
所以那不是上帝，对吧？
So it's like whatever angle you're looking at it from to confirm your bias or your previously held point of view you'll hook into.
所以这就好像无论你从哪个角度去看，来证实你的偏见或你先前持有的观点，你都会将其套用进去。
But I've always loved that, I always, I do think that there is a theological, And I don't know if that's the right word, but there's a cosmic magical realism thing running through the pulse of how I met your mother that I think people really love.
但我一直很喜欢这一点，我一直，我确实认为《老爸老妈浪漫史》的脉络中贯穿着一种神学的——我不知道这词准不准——但有一种宇宙级的奇幻现实主义，我觉得人们真的很喜欢。
I think that's part of its secret magic of why people love it extra special.
我认为这是它让人格外喜爱的秘密魔力的一部分。
I wanna give Carter Bay as a shout out there.
我想在这里向卡特·贝斯（Carter Bays）致敬。
I think that's a real specialty of Carter's.
我认为这是卡特的拿手好戏。
I think Carter has a real, like him pitching you that story and him having that child like grand on his face.
我觉得卡特真的，比如他向你推销这个故事时，脸上带着那种孩子般灿烂的笑容。
So that Ted's gonna make it rain.
所以泰德要求雨停。
That is a very Carter Bay's energy.
这非常符合卡特·贝斯的风格。
And I think that that, I think that this episode captured something very special, that Carter as well.
而且我认为，这一集捕捉到了一些非常特别的东西，卡特也是如此。
So I just wanted to shout that out.
所以我只想向他致敬。
It's almost like rain dances Carter Bay's big foot nalions, Craig Thomas.
这有点像求雨舞是卡特·贝斯的尼斯湖水怪，克雷格·托马斯（Craig Thomas）。
It's like, you guys each had your own kind of areas of magical specialties.
就像你们每个人都有自己擅长的魔力领域一样。
Where are you gonna see the magic?
你要去哪里寻找魔力？
And it's like the magic is in what you choose to include or not in the story.
而且魔力就存在于你选择在故事中包含或不包含什么之中。
What you choose to see as part of the story or maybe your failure to see the magic that's in the story.
你选择将什么视为故事的一部分，或者也许你未能看到故事中蕴含的魔力。
It's like, when you're depressed, you're not seeing the magic.
这就好像，当你情绪低落时，你是看不到魔力的。
And when you're in those up moments where you're actually seeing some shape to your life and realizing like, wait, that's unbelievable that it worked out that way.
而当你处于那些高光时刻，你实际上看到了你生活的某种轮廓，并意识到，等等，事情能那样发展简直太不可思议了。
There's something happening there.
那里正在发生某些事情。
There's some sort of like shape to this that can't be quite explained.
生活中存在着某种无法完全解释的轮廓。
And I think we've all had moments in our life that are one or the other.
我想我们都在生活中经历过这两种时刻。
And this is just both because it's Marshall's worst moment and it's Ted's best moment.
而这一集两者兼有，因为这是马歇尔最糟糕的时刻，也是泰德最好的时刻。
And they happen at the same fucking moment.
偏偏它们发生在同一个该死的时刻。
That rain means something completely different to Marshall than what that rain means to Ted at that moment.
对马歇尔来说，那场雨的意义与那一刻对泰德的意义完全不同。
Like Marshall is getting, to Marshall it is the kind of, the dourness or gloominess of the moment is meeting him.
就像马歇尔正在承受的，对马歇尔来说，那一刻的阴郁或灰暗正迎面扑来。
And the rain is pounding him.
雨水猛烈地敲打着他。
The rain to, the rain to Marshall is tears.
对马歇尔来说，雨就是眼泪。
And the rain to Ted is proof that magic exists and Robin will be mine.
而对泰德来说，雨是奇迹存在的证明，罗宾将属于他。
And how do two best friends share that moment?
两个最好的朋友怎么能共享这样一个时刻？
That moment of you guys on that stoop and how you sit next to him, it makes me cry.
你们坐在台阶上的那个时刻，以及你如何坐在他身旁，让我感动得落泪。
Every single time they're in two different worlds, but they're together.
每一次，他们身处两个不同的世界，但他们在一起。
And Ted knows he needs to be in Marshall's version of the moment, which I love about Ted.
而且泰德知道他得配合马歇尔当时的心情，我特别喜欢泰德这一点。
Again, Ted's loyalty.
再次体现了泰德的义气。
Yeah, it also I think is really smart about how as friends you have to navigate, let's say you're having success or something and your friend is hurting or you're getting married and your friends just getting broken up.
对，而且我觉得这也体现了作为朋友，当你们需要处理某些情况时其实非常明智，比如说你正春风得意而你的朋友却在经历痛苦，或者你要结婚了而你的朋友刚分手。
Like there's so many times where you're not linked up emotionally with your friends and you have to navigate that.
比如有很多时候，你和你朋友的情感并不在同一个频道上，你必须去应对这种情况。
You have to dip into their narrative for a little bit and offer solace and even accept that they might not be in a space where they can be as happy for you as you would wish they would be.
你得暂时融入他们的情绪，给予安慰，甚至得接受这样一种现实：他们此刻可能无法像你所希望的那样为你感到高兴。
When Ted pulls up in the cab and then sees Marshall at Jordana realizing what had happened, She says, they won't let us be happy for one goddamn second.
当泰德坐出租车赶到并看到马歇尔在Jordana餐厅意识到发生了什么时，她说道，他们连让我们高兴哪怕该死的一秒钟都不肯。
Oh my God.
哦，天哪。
And I think Carter and I are the they in that sentence.
我觉得卡特和我就是那句话里的“他们”。
I'm very sorry.
我真的很抱歉。
That's right.
没错。
确实如此。
We are the they.
我们就是那个“他们”。
Oh my God.
哦，天哪。
But I bet she wants to tune in a season two.
但我敢打赌她很想收看第二季。
So we got to.
所以我们得……
She sure does.
她当然想。
It's, look, I mean, story is conflict, right?
你看，我的意思是，故事就是冲突，对吧？
And you need a reason to tune in.
你需要一个让人收看的理由。
It's like, you can't just be like, and then it all worked out, right?
这就好像，你不能只是说，然后一切都圆满解决了，对吧？
But then it all worked out as the role credits, that's the whole show.
要是“然后一切都圆满解决”伴随着演职员表结束，那就是整部剧了。
It's the journey, but it is true.
重点在于过程，不过确实如此。
It is true.
确实如此。
Ted is so euphoric.
泰德当时太狂喜了。
Even riding in that cab with the look on Ted's face with the way you play that, Josh, the Christmas morning euphoria of that makes it such a knockout punch when Ted walks out and finds Marshall on that stoop.
甚至在出租车里时，泰德脸上的表情，还有你当时的演绎方式，乔希，那种圣诞节早晨般的狂喜，使得当泰德走下车发现马歇尔坐在台阶上时，那一幕简直就像是致命的一击。
It is one of my favorite moments in the series, but I acknowledge that it is surfing into a brick wall.
这是我在这部剧里最喜欢的时刻之一，但我承认这就好比一头撞上了一堵砖墙。
Yeah.
对。
It's also great as an actor to know that the assignment was, you go from the happiest you've ever been to, oh my God, my friend, not only is my friend heart broken, but my entire social family has just cracked, you know?
作为演员，这也是一种很棒的体验，你知道任务要求是：你要从有生以来最快乐的状态，瞬间跌落到“哦，天哪，我的朋友不仅心碎了，而且我的整个社交圈也刚刚分崩离析了”，你知道吗？
It's really like, and yes, that's hard, maybe the audience who wants just happy, happy, fun fun.
这真的就好像是，没错，这很难，也许那些只想看纯粹快乐、轻松有趣的观众……
Like maybe they'll be upset about it.
比如他们可能会对此感到沮丧。
But people who are really there for the emotional ride of it, they secretly love this shit.
但那些真正沉浸于情感过山车的观众，他们其实内心深处很喜欢这种狗血剧情。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
Like that's why they want you to.
这就是为什么他们希望你……
They do because also you know that you're not going to it's literally it's a cliffhanger.
他们确实如此，因为你也知道故事不会就此结束——这简直就是一个悬念。
The heroes about to it's not going to make it.
英雄正要……结果撑不下去了。
The story is you know we're not going to figure it out.
故事的发展是，你知道我们不会轻易解决问题。
But you tune in because you're like we want twists and turns we want to we want to see people overcome.
但你之所以会收看，是因为你想看跌宕起伏，我们想看人们战胜困难。
Nick Cave wrote one of my favorite things.
尼克·凯夫写过我最喜欢的一段话。
He's asked, will A.I.
有人问他，人工智能……
ever write a great song?
以后能写出伟大的歌曲吗？
And he said, A.I.
他说，人工智能……
will write a good song, but they'll never write a great song because they can mimic human feeling and they can make you feel all the things that a good song will make you feel, but greatness lies in the fact of a human being transcending limitation.
能写出好歌，但永远写不出伟大的歌，因为它们可以模仿人类的情感，能让你感受到一首好歌本该让你感受到的一切，但伟大之处在于人类能够超越自身的局限性。
But robots and machines don't have limitation, so there's nothing to transcend.
然而机器人和机器是没有局限性的，所以也就没有什么需要超越的。
Therefore, you can't witness greatness because he talks about Kurt Cobain and smells like Teen Spirit.
因此，你无法见证伟大，接着他谈到了库尔特·柯本和《少年心气》。
It's the audacity to try to transcend this little town he grew up in, to transcend his addiction to howl towards heavens, you know, for this generational lament.
正是那种孤注一掷的勇气，去超越他长大的那个小镇，去超越他的毒瘾，去向苍穹怒吼（你知道的），为了这种属于一代人的悲歌。
An AI has never been heartbroken.
人工智能从未心碎过。
An AI has never been addicted to drugs.
人工智能从未对毒品上瘾。
An AI has never lived in a small town and felt stifled by it.
人工智能从未在一个小镇生活过并感到窒息。
There's all these human things that the AI will never be able to transcend.
有所有这些属于人类的事情，人工智能是永远无法超越的。
So I just love, you know, and again watching Ted try to transcend the limitation of a person who doesn't know how to make it rain.
所以我就是喜欢，你知道的，再次看着泰德努力去超越一个不懂得如何呼风唤雨的普通人的局限。
But by golly he does, you know?
但他天生就会，对吧？
Yeah.
对。
Yeah, there's so much humanity in this episode with the AI description would be Ted makes it rain to keep Robin from going camping.
对，这一集里充满了人情味，正如人工智能描述的那样，泰德为了不让罗宾去露营而求雨。
It's like, yeah, those are the facts, but what's the nuance?
就好像，没错，这些是事实，但细微之处在哪里呢？
Yeah, I'm right.
对，我是对的。
That's beautiful.
这太美妙了。
That's exactly it.
完全就是这样。
There has to be skin in the game.
必须得有切身的投入。
There has to be blood in it.
必须得付出血的代价。
And that's what we're going for.
而这正是我们所追求的。
with the ending of the season, I'm kind of thrilled that still 20 years later, it makes people scream at the TV, like even Jordana's like, what are they doing to us?
随着这一季的结束，我其实挺激动的是，20年过去了，它依然能让人对着电视尖叫，甚至连乔丹娜都在说，他们到底对我们做了什么？
It's like we were trying to get that reaction.
这就好比我们当时就是想达到这种反应。
We really were.
我们真的是这么想的。
It's evidence that she was in.
这证明她入戏了。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
Like she was really happy, and then she got pulled back down to Earth just like Ted.
就好像她原本真的很开心，然后却像泰德一样被拉回了现实。
Just, you know what I mean?
就是，你知道我的意思吗？
Like she's, that's where Ted is really the tour guide of the show.
就好像她是，泰德才是这部剧真正的导游。
He's taking you on this emotional tour.
他带你进行了一场情感之旅。
I wish we got two extra minutes at the end of that episode, and we could have had that song play out even more and made that montage a little longer, made the ramp up to Ted Sing, Marshall longer, made the very end a little longer.
我真希望那一集结尾能多给我们两分钟，我们可以让那首歌放得更久一点，让蒙太奇再长一点，让泰德和马歇尔合唱的铺垫再长一点，让最后的结局再稍微长一点。
It's beautiful, I love that song.
太美了，我喜欢那首歌。
That's an amazing song.
那是一首神曲。
This Modern Love by Block Party, one of my favorite music drops that I think we entirely got to that song because Josh, you and Carter went to Coachella.
《This Modern Love》by Block Party，这是我最喜欢的音乐切入之一，我想我们能用上这首歌完全是因为Josh，你和Carter去了科切拉音乐节。
Correct.
没错。
So Block Party, I think.
所以我想是Block Party。
And then you're like, we have to use that song.
然后你就说，我们一定要用这首歌。
So that was like a joint song pitch from you and Carter.
所以这是你和卡特共同推荐的一首歌。
The perfect song, maybe my favorite music needle job and certainly in season one, maybe ever of the whole show.
完美的一首歌，可能是我最喜欢的音乐切入点，在第一季里绝对是，甚至可能是整部剧里最棒的。
It's an amazing song for that moment.
对于那一刻来说，这是一首绝佳的歌。
But just to do, to, behind the scenes for one second, I just want to say this because I do feel like I've heard from some younger like writers who listen to this podcast and directors and produced people who make stuff.
但为了揭秘幕后一分钟，我只想说这些，因为我觉得我确实听到过一些年轻的编剧，比如听这个播客的编剧、导演和制作人们，他们都在创作。
I'll just tell one little story about what happened to us at the end of season one.
我只想讲一个小故事，关于我们在第一季结束时遭遇了什么。
Carner and I went to the sound mix for this episode, which is the last thing for the last episode, for the last, you know, for the end of season one.
卡特和我去参加这一集的混音制作，这是最后一集的最后一道工序，也就是第一季结束时的最后工作。
And from the sound mix we had where you're just putting the cherry on top, you say, all right, we're done with season one and you feel really good.
在完成混音之后，这就好比是在蛋糕上裱了最后一朵花，你会说，好吧，第一季我们完成了，感觉真棒。
We went to a meeting at CBS, which we thought was a meeting about season two, just to give us some feedback and lay out some dates and some plans, but it was like a big meeting, the head of CBS, the head of our home studio 20th, the presidents of that studio were going.
我们去CBS开了一个会，我们以为那是一个关于第二季的会议，只是给我们一些反馈，列出一些日期和计划，但那是一个很大的会议，CBS的负责人，我们的大本营制片厂20th的负责人，那个制片厂的总裁们都要去。
And it was a lot of people at the meeting, a lot of department heads from marketing and this and that.
会上有很多 人，有很多来自市场部和其他各个部门的负责人。
We thought it was about season two.
我们以为是关于第二季的。
Instead, we walked in having, again, it basically just finished the marathon, break the tape, collapse after this 26 mile run, and if you pour in water on your head, you limp into this meeting and they go, we don't like what you've done here.
相反，我们走进去的时候——再次强调，我们基本上刚跑完马拉松，冲过终点线，在跑了26英里后累得瘫倒，头上被浇了水，一瘸一拐地走进这个会议室，然后他们说：我们不喜欢你们在这里做的事。
And the reason they didn't like what we had done here, well the real reason is that we were starting to lose to that show where Howie Mandel would open suitcases full of money and it was starting to get better ratings than us.
他们不喜欢我们在这里做的事的原因，嗯，真正的其实是我们当时开始输给那个节目——豪伊·曼德尔会打开装满现金的手提箱那个节目，它的收视率开始比我们高了。
That's why they had, that was their bigger concern, which I share that concern.
这就是他们当时有的，那是他们更大的担忧，我也同样有这种担忧。
I also was disturbed by that turn of events, but we were starting to get beaten in the ratings by that show, which is the briefcase full of money show.
我也对事态的这种转变感到不安，但我们的收视率确实开始被那个节目超越了，也就是那个装满钱的手提箱的节目。
Deal or no deal, I think it was called, but so, which has really stood the test of time too.
我想它叫《一掷千金》，不过所以，这个节目也确实经受住了时间的考验。
Who's not watching that?
谁不看那个？
I'm Netflix and he was a little.
我在Netflix上……他有点……
I listen to how we made deal or no deal every week.
我每周都听豪伊制作的《一掷千金》。
Yeah.
对。
How we deal or no deal.
豪伊的《一掷千金》。
So, yeah, it's very, it's oddly pensive and reflective.
所以，是的，它非常，它有一种奇怪的沉思和反思感。
Howie Mandel is just going very deep.
豪伊·曼德尔正在进行非常深刻的探讨。
Cause that, what's in the briefcase is what's in our soul.
因为那个，手提箱里装的东西就是我们灵魂里装的东西。
Well, you, we definitely check that podcast out next once this one's over.
好吧，你，等这个播客结束后，我们接下来一定要去看看那个播客。
But we were losing, we were getting creamed by what's in the briefcase and our ratings dipped a bit.
但我们当时在输，我们被“手提箱里有什么”那个节目打得落花流水，我们的收视率下降了一点。
And we got called into a meeting.
然后我们被叫去开会。
And I will say this by calling the meeting with a bunch of very nice people who had believed in the show till that point and Hemium style flash forward continued later to very much believe it and support the show creatively too.
我要说的是，召集这个会议的是一群非常好的人，他们到那时为止一直对这部剧深信不疑，而且在未来的发展中也极大地相信并从创意上支持这部剧。
But at the end of season one, there was a bad moment, a moment of doubt.
但在第一季结束时，那是一个糟糕的时刻，一个充满怀疑的时刻。
And they thought the thesis given to us was the reason you're losing out to briefcase full of money show is that you're too serialized, you're asking too much of the audience, you're too emo, it's too emotional, you're counting on the audience to watch every episode and track these arcs and these narratives.
他们给我们的核心观点是，你们之所以输给手提箱节目，是因为你们的连续性太强了，你们对观众要求太高了，你们太情绪化了，太有情感共鸣了，你们指望观众观看每一集并追踪这些故事线和叙事。
And I'm sure it didn't help the final two minutes of the season was magical realism in which a guy makes it rain.
而且我敢肯定，这一季最后两分钟是魔幻现实主义——一个家伙让天上下雨，这绝对没什么帮助。
And then comes home and sees his heart broken best friends on the steps.
然后回到家，看到他心碎的最好朋友们坐在台阶上。
And the last shot is pulling back shot in the rain of the highs and the lows of life set to a indie rock song by a very cool British band.
最后一个镜头是在雨中拉远镜头，展现生活的起起落落，配上一支非常酷的英国乐队的独立摇滚歌曲。
That finishes and along you could flip the channel and Howie Mandel's like, there's money in here.
这首歌播完，你一换台，豪伊·曼德尔就会说：“这里面有钱啊。”
And at nine o'clock, you're going to like two and a half men and it's Charlie Sheen.
到了九点钟，你会看《好汉两个半》，里面是查理·辛。
And like we were fucking weird.
就像我们当时他妈的好怪。
We were a fucking weird show.
我们是一部他妈的好怪的剧。
We were the black sheep on CBS.
我们是CBS的害群之马。
We are probably the black sheep of eight thirty to nine thirty on network TV because what the fuck were we doing with this guy making it rain?
我们可能是电视网黄金档八点半到九点半时段的异类，因为我们让这个家伙求雨到底是在搞什么鬼？
Hey, Howie Mandel was making it rain.
嘿，豪伊·曼德尔当时在让钱下雨呢。
Every night he was making it rain.
他每天晚上都在让钱下雨。
So much rain.
下了那么多的雨。
The best kind of rain is a green kind.
最好的雨是绿色的那种。
If we've gotten canceled after season one, I think we would have been, you know, it would have been another Jason Segal classic that got canceled after one season.
如果我们第一季后被砍了，我想我们就会，你知道的，就会成为另一个只播了一季就被砍的杰森·席格尔经典作品。
You know, like it would have been, I think a kind of freaks and geeks.
你知道的，就像会成为那种《怪胎与书呆》一样。
A noble, a failover where the network gets kicked.
一个高尚的、遭到电视台抛弃的失败之作。
But for some weird cosmic reason, it feels like because we, through some sort of, I don't know what kept us on the air, but there was something I think we were more on the bubble than we thought we were.
但出于某种奇怪的宇宙原因，感觉好像是因为我们，通过某种——我不知道是什么让我们得以留在荧屏上，但我认为我们的处境比我们想象的还要如履薄冰。
We were on the bubble.
我们当时确实如履薄冰。
We were definitely on the bubble.
我们绝对如履薄冰。
Here's the end of that story.
故事的结局是这样的。
We're in this big conference room with this huge table full of people.
我们坐在这个巨大的会议室里，周围是一张坐满人的大桌子。
It was the heads of the studio, the heads of the network.
在场的有制片厂的负责人，电视台的负责人。
And we are to remind me of that scene where Joe Pashi and Goodfellas, he thinks he's walking in to become a made man and have this great positive meeting and then instead he's assassinated.
这让我想起《好家伙》里的那个场景，乔·佩西以为自己走进去是要成为一个正式成员，开一个非常积极的棒会，结果却被暗杀了。
That was how the meeting felt a little bit, or Carter and I were a little bit like, oh, this is not the meeting we thought.
那个会议给人的感觉有点像这样，卡特和我当时都有点觉得，哦，这根本不是我们以为的那种会议。
And we were just told like be less serialized, be less emo, more standalone episodes, come on and you have a great cast, don't throw this thing away.
我们当时被告知：要减少连续剧集，少一点情绪化，多做一些独立成章的得单集，拜托，你们有这么棒的演员阵容，别把这事搞砸了。
Don't throw this thing away by being so heady and emotional and intricately serialized, all that kind of stuff.
别因为太深奥、太情绪化、连续性太复杂而把这事给毁了，诸如此类的话。
Flash forward to season two, we didn't stop doing any of that stuff if anything we did it more.
快进到第二季，我们不仅没有停止做那些事，如果有的话，我们反而变本加厉了。
So the point of my story is stick to your guns.
所以我这个故事的重点是：坚持你们的立场。
The point of the story is we believed that the audience was there for this type of show with this tone, maybe our ratings had dipped a little, maybe we were gonna be a slow burn, maybe we were gonna have people find us and we just had to hang out till that happened.
这个故事的重点是，我们相信观众是会为了这种风格的剧集而来的，也许我们的收视率下降了一点，也许我们会经历一个慢热的过程，也许我们要等待人们发现我们，而我们只需要坚持到那一刻的到来。
It started to happen more in season two, it started to happen more in season three.
这种情况在第二季开始更多地发生，在第三季开始更多地发生。
The show got on Netflix, that really made it start to happen.
这部剧上了Netflix，这真的让这种情况开始爆发了。
And all of a sudden everyone was consuming television in the way that rewarded serialized storytelling, emotional storytelling, intricate, playful, curious, weird, abstract, creative storytelling.
突然之间，所有人都在以一种奖励连续性叙事、情感叙事、复杂、好玩、好奇、古怪、抽象、有创意的叙事方式来消费电视节目。
And we just were able to weather that storm.
而我们安然度过了那场风暴。
And again, by that point, all those same people who had expressed that concern at the end of season one kind of went, we get it.
而且再次强调，到了那个时候，所有那些在第一季结束时表达过担忧的人都说：我们懂了。
We see what you're doing and it's working.
我们看懂了你们在做什么，而且它确实有效。
And they did stick by us.
他们确实一直支持我们。
Carter and I thought we were gonna get fired.
卡特和我当时以为我们要被炒鱿鱼了。
We didn't even necessarily think the show was gonna get canceled, but we're like, are we gonna get fired off our own show, which has happened?
我们甚至不一定觉得这节目会被砍，但我们在想，我们会不会被自己的节目开除？这种事以前也发生过。
Because it's like, the feeling was you're squandering this opportunity because you're telling stories in this crazy way.
因为当时的感觉是，你们在挥霍这个机会，因为你们在用这种疯狂的方式讲故事。
And we disagreed, a pan-fryment disagreed, you guys, the cast disagreed, you all had faith in us.
而我们不同意，帕姆弗莱明也不同意，你们不同意，演员阵容不同意，你们所有人都对我们有信心。
And we basically just doubled down and kept doing it.
我们基本上就是孤注一掷，继续干下去。
We didn't change much of anything in season two.
我们在第二季几乎没怎么改变。
If anything, we just did it more.
硬要说的话，我们只是做得更过火了。
So I'm very proud that we stuck with what the vision was, and I'm so happy it worked out in the end.
所以我非常为我们坚持了最初的愿景感到自豪，我也很高兴它最终成功了。
Well, it's almost like TV shows are not unlike romance, right?
嗯，这简直就像电视剧跟恋爱有几分类似，对吧？
Where things can line up, they can be the right people wrong time, right?
各种因素可能刚好对上，也可能是遇到对的人却在不对的时间，对吧？
And so much had to break our way, like truly, like I remember when we went on Netflix.
而且有太多事情必须按我们的预期发展，真的，就像我记得我们上线Netflix的时候。
And it was, I remember breaking bad was kind of a quiet, critically beloved, but kind of quiet show.
当时，我记得《绝命毒师》也算是一部比较低调、评论界很喜欢，但热度不高的剧。
And then it went on Netflix and it just became a phenomenon.
然后它上了Netflix，就变成了一种现象级作品。
And a similar thing happened to us.
我们也有过类似的经历。
I do remember very strongly, I think it was fourth season.
我印象非常深刻，好像是第四季的时候。
We were sitting around on a Tuesday waiting to start or maybe we were waiting for the execs to come.
我们周二正坐在一起等着开工，或者也许我们在等高管们过来。
I think it was that.
我想就是那样。
We were waiting for everyone to come down for a tablery, I mean for the run through.
我们在等所有人下来进行围读，我是说为了排练走场。
And I remember Jason said to us, are things getting weird for you guys out here?
我记得杰森对我们说，你们有没有觉得外面的情况变得有点奇怪了？
Anyone else?
还有别人吗？
like meaning he was getting recognized for the show more than ever and before we always said we were like this sleepy little sleeper we were we were beloved by the people that were watching but otherwise we were whatever but when it went on Netflix people just caught it it started spreading around we all started to feel like we were more on a hit television show than we had ever felt we hadn't felt that the first three seasons and so much had to go right it was like we had all the the right elements.
意思是说他比以往任何时候都更容易在街上被认出来，而在此之前，我们总是说自己是一部默默无闻的黑马剧，我们深受那些看剧观众的喜爱，但除此之外，我们就什么也不是了，不过当它登陆Netflix后，人们一下子就迷上了，开始口耳相传，我们所有人都开始觉得我们真正置身于一部大热电视剧中，这种感觉比以往任何时候都要强烈，前三季我们可没这种感觉，而且有太多环节必须顺利推进，就像我们集齐了所有正确的要素。
I think what the executives were saying was we know we have something special here.
我觉得高管们当时想表达的是，我们知道我们手头有个好东西。
They were just trying to figure out how to keep it, you know, to make it blaze a little brighter, right?
他们只是在想方设法留住它，你知道的，让它更火爆一点，对吧？
I genuinely believe that.
我真心这么觉得。
I really do think they loved it.
我是真的觉得他们很喜欢这部剧。
They were good people and they did stick by the show.
他们都是很好的人，也确实一直支持着这部剧。
They were concerned at that one moment and the ending is happy because these were executives that did stick with believing in us, believing in the show.
他们在某个时刻确实担忧过，但结局是美好的，因为这些高管确实一直选择相信我们，相信这部剧。
I feel like the show was doing a rain dance.
我觉得这部剧当时就像是在跳求雨舞。
The show itself was doing Ted's rain dance on the roof saying, And please come on, come on, come on, and the universe, it delivered for us in the end.
剧集本身就像泰德在屋顶上跳求雨舞一样，喊着：“拜托，来吧，来吧，来吧”，而最终，命运之神还是眷顾了我们。
And thank you.
谢谢大家。
谢谢你们。
Honestly, thank you to the fans.
说真的，感谢粉丝们。
Yeah.
是啊。
Well, why don't we, let's go through, like, these were kind of my notes that I really liked.
好吧，我们为什么不——我们来看看，这些差不多就是我真的很喜欢的笔记。
What was the thing Marshall said, whoa, chills.
马歇尔说的那句是什么来着，哇，鸡皮疙瘩都起来了。
Anyone else get chills?
还有其他人起鸡皮疙瘩吗？
What was that at the beginning?
刚开始的时候那是哪一句？
He says to Ted, unless your dating life is the clue of holding the entire universe together, chills.
他对泰德说，除非你的约会生活是维系整个宇宙的关键线索，天哪，鸡皮疙瘩。
chills.
鸡皮疙瘩。
I love that line because it's the stakes of the whole show.
我太喜欢这句台词了，因为它奠定了整部剧的立意。
Ted's dating life is the universe, right?
泰德的约会生活就是整个宇宙，对吧？
The universe of the show is that that's the universe of the story.
剧中的宇宙就是，那就是故事的宇宙。
So it's actually kind of true.
所以这其实也算某种事实。
Right.
没错。
It's almost like he's saying like, what if we're a part of a story that's being told?
这就好像他在说，如果我们只是某个正在被讲述的故事的一部分呢？
It's very simulation theory.
这非常符合模拟理论。
It is a simulation theory.
这确实是模拟理论。
I love when Sandy River says, camping out in the rain, muddy yuck.
我喜欢桑迪·里弗斯说的那句，在雨中露营，满地泥泞真恶心。
I wrote that one down to muddy.
我把这句记下来了，真泥泞。
It's it just he has nothing to say.
这——他简直无话可说。
If he's not given it, he's one of those talking heads that has nothing to say except what's on the teleprompter.
如果没人给他写台词，他就是那种除了提词器上显示的内容外什么也说不出来的名嘴。
He really can't get it through a meaningful sentence.
他真的说不出一句有意义的话。
His pink shirt and pink tie is amazing and his freak juice flowing line is also amazing.
他的粉色衬衫和粉色领带太棒了，他那句“怪胎体液四处流淌”的台词也绝了。
I loved hearing, so we had a script supervisor named Janet Kagan who was this hilarious, lovely, delightful British woman who was always at a podium just to the side of the monitors with Pam Fryman, we would gather around for nine years.
我很高兴听到——我们曾有一位名叫珍妮特·卡根的剧本总监，她是一个搞笑、可爱、讨人喜欢的英国女性，总是站在监视器旁边的讲台旁，和帕姆·弗莱曼一起，九年来我们一直围聚在那里。
We gathered around her podium before big scenes.
在重要场景拍摄前，我们都会围在她的讲台周围。
We ran lines with her.
我们和她一起对台词。
She was so funny, such a delightful essential presence on the stage.
她太有趣了，是片场一个可爱且不可或缺的存在。
But we hear her voice.
但我们听到了她的声音。
I think she even says, this is Janet Kagan.
我想她甚至说过，这是珍妮特·卡根。
She's the one who offers Alia, her summer fellowship acceptance, right?
就是那个给阿莉娅提供暑期奖学金录取通知的人，对吧？
That Marshall hears.
马歇尔听到了。
Yeah, that's right.
对，没错。
So just a shout out to Janet.
所以向珍妮特致敬。
That's right.
没错。
We love Janet.
我们爱珍妮特。
I will say that I am not a fan of the gesture that Ted is a fan of over the top.
我要说的是，我不喜欢泰德喜欢的那种过于夸张的示爱方式。
Like hiring a blue string quartet.
比如雇一个蓝色弦乐四重奏。
Plus, how many roses there had to have been, like, eight dozen roses, and, like, he's an architect.
另外，还得有多少玫瑰啊，大概有八打玫瑰吧，而且，他是个建筑师。
He's a young architect.
他是个年轻的建筑师。
He's not making that much money.
他没挣那么多钱。
Like, it's an absurd gesture.
所以，这是一种荒谬的举动。
And I think that her kind of allergy to it is appropriate.
我觉得她那种排斥的反应是很恰当的。
And it's one of those things when people ask me, like, what do I love about him?
这就是那种人们会问我：“我喜欢他什么？
What do I hate about him?
我讨厌他什么？”的时候……
This is something I don't particularly like about him.
这就是我不怎么喜欢他的地方。
I think it's over the top.
我觉得这太夸张了。
I think it's, I think it's a little creepy and I think it's, it's sometimes really misplaced.
我觉得这有点让人毛骨悚然，而且有时候真的很不合时宜。
Like he, the, the, the, the 10 I like is, um, my gesture is, I put on a bleach stained sweatshirt and I come to your cupcake shop and I kiss you.
就像他，我喜欢的那个，嗯，我的示爱方式是，我穿着一件有漂白剂污渍的卫衣，来到你的纸杯蛋糕店，然后吻你。
Like that to me is just, is just more.
对我来说，那种方式才更……更有意义。
I think he, um, because he started the robin adventure with this grand gesture of stealing the blue French horn.
我觉得他，嗯，因为他最初通过偷蓝色法国号这个宏大的举动开始了对罗宾的追求。
I think he tries to up the ante and it's just something that makes my skin crawl a little bit.
我觉得他想变本加厉，这让我有点起鸡皮疙瘩。
I just want to say that.
我只想说这些。
I agree.
我同意。
Well, I think you notice in the season one, like when he tries to do the perfect thing, it doesn't work.
嗯，我觉得你在第一季里会发现，当他试图做完美的事情时，往往行不通。
When he puts on the sweatshirt with the bleach stain, it does.
当他穿上带有漂白剂污渍的卫衣时，却成功了。
Yeah.
是的。
And even in this one, this gesture does not work, but the sort of messy and insane and unhinged thing that is not at all traditionally romantic, the rain dance, the act of faith and asking the universe for help, that's what works, not the roses.
甚至在这一集里，这种示爱方式也没有用，但那种凌乱、疯狂、歇斯底里、一点也不传统浪漫的事情——那场求雨舞、那次信念之举、向宇宙寻求帮助，这才是起作用的，而不是玫瑰。
I feel like there's interesting lesson there.
我觉得这里面有一个有趣的教训。
And I think it's in accord with what you just said.
我觉得这与你刚才所说的不谋而合。
I also think there's, I remember you guys said that Ted was pitched as Lloyd Dobler meets George Bailey from It's A Wonderful Life.
我还觉得，我记得你们说过，泰德被塑造成了《生活多美好》里的罗伊·多布勒（Lloyd Dobler）遇见乔治·贝利（George Bailey）的结合体。
And I think that there's a thing you can watch on YouTube of like all the times that John Cusack has been rained on.
我觉得你可以在YouTube上看到一个视频，盘点了约翰·库萨克所有淋雨的镜头。
I think he's been one of the most rained on actors in cinema history.
我觉得他是电影史上被雨淋得最多的演员之一。
And I think that was a little wink to the Cusakian film bio that he was getting just doused.
我觉得当他被淋得透湿时，这也是对库萨克式电影风格的一种小小的致敬。
Absolutely.
绝对是。
I mean, there's just such a power to seeing you out there in the rain, that big crane shot, the big jib shot looking down on you, and you're getting fully doused, and you are really soaked.
我是说，看到你站在雨中真的有一种强大的感染力，那个巨大的摇臂镜头俯视着你，你完全被淋透了，真的湿透了。
You're looking up, it's getting in your eyes.
你抬起头，雨水流进你的眼睛。
You can't replicate the performance that you achieved in that moment partially because of that rain and going into your eyes and washing down your face.
你无法复制你在那一刻达到的表演效果，部分原因就是因为那些雨水流进你的眼睛并顺着你的脸流淌下来。
It really changes the energy, doesn't it?
这真的改变了那种氛围，不是吗？
I always loved, one, we've talked about it, going down to New York Street, where you would just, you know, you would either take a golf cart, or I like actually walking down to New York Street, but it was like a eight to 10 minutes stroll down to New York Street from stage 22.
我一直很喜欢，第一，我们讨论过，走到纽约街，你知道，你要么坐高尔夫球车，或者我其实喜欢步行去纽约街，从22号摄影棚步行到纽约街大约需要八到十分钟。
And you're in Southern California.
而你身处南加州。
It's almost never raining like that.
几乎从不下这种雨。
So they would bring in this huge tanker of rainwater and they just wouldn't make it rain on the stage.
所以他们会运来这辆巨大的雨水罐车，然后直接在摄影棚里人工降雨。
And I always felt like when I was on the stage getting, and when I was on New York Street getting rained on, I felt like I've made it in show business.
每当我站在摄影棚里淋雨，当我站在纽约街淋雨的时候，我总觉得自己已经在演艺界闯出名堂了。
Like there was such a feeling of like old, tiny Hollywood, you know, New York Street getting rained on.
那种感觉就像老派的好莱坞，你知道的，纽约街在下着雨。
It was such a sweet, cool feeling of make believe, but real, like it was just, I just loved it.
那是一种非常甜蜜、酷炫的虚构感，但又如此真实，我简直太喜欢了。
So I think part of my joy is in the character, I'm in the moment.
所以我认为我的快乐有一部分源于这个角色，我正身处其中。
It's the Hollywood of the end of PB's big adventure.
这就是《皮威的大历险》结尾时那种好莱坞的感觉。
Yeah.
是的。
I'm in the joy of the character, but I'm also in the joy of the actor getting to do this fun thing.
我既沉浸在角色的快乐中，也为演员能演到这么有趣的东西感到高兴。
Just to point out, Alexis Dennisov is wonderful in this episode.
顺便指出，埃利克西斯·丹尼斯托夫在这集里表现得太棒了。
So is Amy Acker, who plays Barney's quote unquote X, who he dated twice, who knows about Native American culture, and is studying it in grad school.
艾米·阿克也是，她饰演巴尼的所谓的前女友，他俩约会过两次，她了解美洲原住民文化，并且正在读研究生。
And she is from the show, Angel, where she was a co-star and eventually love interest of Alexis' character on Angel.
她来自电视剧《天使》，在那里她是艾利克西斯角色的联合主演，后来成了恋人。
Angels to spin off from Buffy.
《天使》是《吸血鬼巴菲》的衍生剧。
I love both shows, started Carter.
这两部剧我都爱，卡特先开的。
So it was wonderful to have an angel mini reunion in this episode.
所以能在这一集里看到《天使》剧组的迷你重聚真是太棒了。
And also for the sharp-eyed vampire Lou is of course Lou the weatherman.
还有，对于眼光敏锐的吸血鬼迷来说，露当然就是那个天气预报员露。
She really, she was wonderful, Amy.
她真的很棒，艾米。
Jordana even said, I really like her.
乔丹娜甚至说，我真的很喜欢她。
She's great, you know?
她太棒了，你知道吗？
I just thought she was such a winning presence.
我只是觉得她身上有一种非常讨喜的气质。
And really, she gave it to Barney in a really funny way that I thought was really quite charming.
而且说实话，她以一种非常有趣的方式回击了巴尼，我觉得相当迷人。
I loved when Barney said, you're forcing me to be the voice of reason it's not a good look for me.
我喜欢巴尼说的那句：“你逼我当理智的声音，这造型可真不适合我。”
I loved Craig.
我喜欢克雷格。
I loved pause.
我喜欢“暂停”。
Where did pause come from?
“暂停”是从哪里来的？
It's such a, it's actually quite a smart relationship tactic, but where did that come from?
这真是一个——其实是一个相当聪明的恋爱策略，但这招是打哪儿来的？
Do you remember?
你还记得吗？
It is a very, it is a very good relationship tactic.
这确实是一个非常、非常好的恋爱策略。
I think that is something to steal from.
我觉得这是个可以借鉴的方法。
I think it was invented.
我想这是发明出来的。
I can't remember if anyone in the room really did that.
我记不清编剧室里是不是真有人这么干过。
I have a faint memory, like maybe somebody did, but we may have invented it for Marshall and Lily, who have been together long enough to have created something like that, right?
我有个模糊的记忆，好像有人这么干过，但我们可能是为马歇尔和莉莉发明的这招，他们在一起的时间足够长，可以创造出这样的东西，对吧？
They've been, they're the old married couple in their late 20s.
他们一直在，他们是快三十岁的老夫老妻了。
And I think they've come up with something that has helped them get this far, except we see that tactic run out of gas here in the end to it doesn't quite save them this time.
我想他们想出了一个能帮他们走到这一步的办法，只不过我们看到这招到最后在这里耗尽了油，这次它不太管用了。
In Red Lobster, like they can't, like pauses may be effective in some ways, but when you have that tsunami of emotions behind it, it's like you can only pause so much and and something's gonna come up and take over.
在红龙虾餐厅里，就像他们不能……暂停在某些方面可能有效，但当你的背后积压了海啸般的情绪时，就像你只能暂停那么多次，然后总会有些东西爆发并占据主导。
That's a great, yeah.
真是个绝妙的，对。
I love that their whole story is amazing and heartbreaking.
我喜欢他们的整个故事，既惊艳又让人心碎。
They're so heartbreaking in this one.
他们在这一集里太让人心碎了。
Watching them unravel and still be adorable at the same time and crying, getting lobster.
看着他们情绪崩溃，却又同时保持可爱，一边哭一边吃龙虾。
And still loving each other so much, yeah.
而且依然深爱着彼此，对。
Still loving each other.
依然深爱着彼此。
It's not that, it's not that they're not in love.
并不是说，并不是说他们不爱对方了。
It's just they're discovering they're in two different places at this moment.
只是他们发现此时此刻彼此身处两个不同的世界。
And that's really fucking hard and really scary.
而这真的他妈的好难，也真的好吓人。
They've been in the same place till now.
在此之前他们可都是在同一个频道上的。
You know what was really startling to me and really beautiful was Ali, just the ferociousness with which he kisses him to get him to stop.
你知道让我感到最吃惊也最美妙的是什么吗，是艾莉，她用那种凶猛的劲头亲吻他，想让他闭嘴。
I was gonna say, yeah, I really felt like.
我正要说呢，对，我真的觉得……
And you think it's gonna work.
而且你以为这招会管用。
You think it's gonna work?
你以为这招会管用？
That's the great part about that.
这正是妙不可言的地方。
Yeah.
对。
You think that's the end of the story?
你以为故事就这样结束了？
Yeah.
对。
That's what's so good about that moment.
这就是那个时刻最棒的地方。
But I just love the passion.
但我就是喜欢那种激情。
Like you see that this is not like an old married couple.
就像你能看出这不像是一对老夫老妻。
Like they're still really hot for each other.
就像他们依然对彼此充满激情。
they're still really, they still really feel it.
他们依然，他们内心深处依然很有感觉。
And, you know, it's also a kind of, it's a young tactic to try to like, I can't, we can't talk about this anymore.
而且，你知道，这也是一种，这是一种很幼稚的策略，就像是，我不能，我们不能再谈这个了。
Let's just go have sex, you know?
我们直接去上床吧，你知道吗？
Like it's, I mean, sometimes that can work.
就像是，我的意思是，有时候这确实管用。
Let's bang our way out of this.
让我们用做爱来解决问题吧。
Yeah, let's bang our way out of this, exactly.
对，让我们用做爱来摆脱困境，完全正确。
Sometimes that can work, but it is, it's a great mislead for the audience.
有时候这管用，但它对观众来说是个很大的误导。
But I think, I think, you know, whenever you guys threw us these big, dramatic scenes that almost could be in a play on Broadway, you know?
不过我觉得，我觉得，你知道吧，每当你们抛给我们这些大型、富有戏剧性的场景，几乎就像百老汇戏剧里的情节一样，你知道吗？
Like they get to, you can see that, that Neil, and I'm not Neil, Jason and Ali are just like, they're so present with each other.
就像他们能，你能看出，尼尔，我不是尼尔，杰森和阿里，他们就是那种，他们彼此非常投入。
They're so, they're so, they're just acting their fucking asses off and it's such a pleasure to watch us and my comrades take this so seriously, you know?
他们是那么地，他们是那么地，他们简直是在倾尽全力地飙演技，看着我和我的战友们能把这事看得这么严肃，真是一种享受，你知道吗？
No one was phoning this stuff in, especially in scenes like that.
没有人是在敷衍了事，尤其是在这种场景里。
I remember feeling heartbroken watching that, right?
我记得看那一幕时心碎的感觉，对吧？
And I remember the whole crew, it's like, it was funeral, right?
而且我记得整个剧组，那种感觉就像是一场葬礼，对吧？
It was like, we all love them so much and we're watching them fall apart.
就好像，我们都那么爱他们，而我们却在看着他们分崩离析。
And it goes silent on the stage because you feel everybody on that crew caring about this couple so much who are not real people, but it feels so real.
舞台上一片寂静，因为你能感觉到那个剧组里的每个人都那么在乎这对情侣，虽然他们不是真人，但感觉却如此真实。
And that's, those are the moments when you feel like the boom mic operator, when you feel the camera operator, when you feel them leaning in like, holy shit, I can't believe they're having this big of a fight.
那就是，那些时刻，当你能感受到收音师、当你能感受到摄像师时，你会发现他们都在倾身向前，仿佛在想，天哪，我不敢相信他们竟然在吵这么大一架。
Those are the moments you're like, this may be a TV show, this may go a few seasons because we're all fucking in here.
在那些时刻，你会觉得，这可能只是一部电视剧，这可能会拍好几季，因为我们全都他妈的全身心投入进去了。
We had to depend on our crew as our first fans and our first viewers.
我们不得不依赖我们的剧组作为我们的第一批粉丝和第一批观众。
And like, I remember like how much Bruce loved the show, how much rabbit loved the show, how much just people would tell you they'd been on enough shows to know, you know when you're on a turkey, you know when you're on a show that you're kind of like, this is a paycheck and it's gonna be good, I'm gonna feed my family and this is the business I'm in and it's fine.
而且，我记得布鲁斯有多么喜欢这部剧，兔子有多么喜欢这部剧，人们会告诉你，他们参与过足够多的剧，所以心里有数——你知道什么时候你是在拍一部烂剧，你知道什么时候你拍的剧会让你觉得：这只是一份薪水，反正拍出来效果不错，我能养活家人，这就是我从事的行业，挺好的。
But it's extra special when you get to do the same job in love what you're filming, love the sound you're catching.
但当你能做着同样的工作，并且热爱你所拍摄的内容、热爱你所收录的声音时，那就格外特别了。
And the crew was always, they were so invested.
而且剧组总是，他们投入得太深了。
And I think the thing with Marshall and Lily is, you know, Ted was just up, he was down, he was having victories, he was getting punched around.
我觉得马歇尔和莉莉的情况是这样的，你知道，泰德总是起起落落，他有过高光时刻，也有过挫折，他挨过生活的一记记闷棍。
He was really the one who was always kind of up in the air.
他真的是那个总是处于飘忽不定状态的人。
Barney is, you know, doing his Barney stuff.
巴尼呢，你知道，就在那里搞他那一套巴尼式的把戏。
Robin was trying to figure out who she was.
罗宾则一直在努力弄清楚她自己是谁。
If there's one thing you could depend upon emotionally in the first season, you're like, well, if anything in this crazy world of how we met your mother is solid, it's this Marshall and Lily couple.
如果在第一季中有什么是你能在情感上依仗的，你会想，好吧，如果《老爸老妈的浪漫史》这个疯狂世界里有什么是坚如磐石的话，那就是马歇尔和莉莉这对情侣。
Like they give us hope that you can make it work, you can have a relationship, and the moment Ted gets his victory, that relationship falls apart.
就像他们给了我们希望，证明你可以让感情维持下去，你可以拥有一段稳定的关系，然而就在泰德迎来胜利的这一刻，那段关系却分崩离析了。
And it's quite devastating because it pulled the rug out from under one of the big promises of the show, is there's one couple that really is here to stay.
这相当令人崩溃，因为它抽掉了这部剧最大的承诺之一——即这里有一对真正能长相厮守的情侣——脚下的地毯。
Yeah, and I think it's very seismic.
对，而且我认为这是具有颠覆性的。
It's seismic for the group, it's seismic for everybody.
对整个团队来说是颠覆性的，对所有人来说都是颠覆性的。
The fact that it's pouring down rain feels like somehow both Ted and the end of Marshall and the Lee's relationship both made it rain in different ways.
倾盆大雨的特效感觉就像是，不知为何，泰德的经历以及马歇尔和莉莉关系的破裂，在不同的层面上都“召唤”来了这场雨。
And it's huge, it's a huge moment.
这是一个巨大的时刻，一个极其重大的时刻。
It's a very powerful feeling moment and I feel that power there acting is so powerful, you're acting is so powerful.
这是一个充满力量、让人动情的时刻，我能感受到那种力量，演技太有力量了，你们的演技太有力量了。
You guys meeting up in these completely different moments, you're almost under two different rain clouds sitting on one stoop, it's so powerful.
你们在这些完全不同的时刻相遇，你们几乎就像是坐在同一个门阶上、却顶着两团不同的雨云，这太震撼了。
That moment, it's one of my favorite moments of the entire series, you and Jason, sitting there on that front stoop.
那个时刻，是我整部剧中最喜欢的时刻之一，你和杰森一起坐在那个前门阶上。
And yeah, it's great, I loved that.
是的，太棒了，我很喜欢那个。
I loved the ending of that episode.
我喜欢那一集的结局。
It's one of my all-time favorites.
那是我有史以来最喜欢的剧集之一。
Well, this is a section, a segment of the show we like to call.
好了，这是节目中我们喜欢称之为的一个环节。
Questions and observations from a clinical psychologist who's never seen how I met your mother and also happens to be married to Josh.
来自一位从未看过《老爸老妈的浪漫史》、且恰好是乔斯妻子的临床心理学家的提问与观察。
I saw a friend this weekend who loves him and she listened to some of my questions and she said, okay, that's fine, but what I really want to hear about is what it's like for you to watch Josh on TV.
这周末我见了一个很喜欢他的朋友，她听了我的一些问题后说：“好吧，这没关系，但我真正想听的是，看乔斯在电视上出现对你来说是什么体验。”
So I'll answer that.
那我就来回答这个问题。
I'll say it's thrilling and also somewhat surreal.
我会说这既让人兴奋又有些超现实。
First of all, and I tell Josh this all the time, I think he's an extraordinary actor and hilarious and I'm so proud when watching him in his craft.
首先，我总是对乔斯说，我认为他是一位非凡的演员，非常搞笑，每当看到他在施展才华时，我都感到无比骄傲。
And it's a very special thing to laugh at something he's done on TV or face he's made and simultaneously get to hold his hand.
而且，一边看着他在电视上做出的某个举动或露出的某种表情而忍俊不禁，一边同时握着他的手，这是一种非常奇妙的体验。
But it's also very strange, you know?
但这也非常诡异，你知道吗？
I feel like I'm watching my husband, but not my husband, watching a version of him without the 20 years of wisdom that he's gained over time and has now, you know, I'm watching not yet the man that I met but the seeds of that man and I'm also watching him play a version of a character that he has some overlap with but is he's ultimately very different from Ted.
我觉得我看到的是我的丈夫，但又不是我的丈夫，我看到的是一个没有随着时间推移而积累下这二十年智慧、还不具备如今这种成熟度的他——你知道的，我看到的还不是我当年认识的那个男人，而是那个男人的雏形；同时我也在看他饰演一个角色，这个角色与他有一些重合之处，但归根结底和泰德有着很大的不同。
So it's him but it's not him which is something we've unpacked and talked about a lot what it was like to be known as someone called the name of someone that he wasn't.
所以那既是他又不是他，这也是我们经常剖析和讨论的话题——被当成一个名字不属于自己的人去认识，究竟是什么感觉。
So as his wife, I'm personally glad I didn't see the show before we met and I'm glad I waited this long to watch so that I never get confused, I never conflate the two.
所以作为他的妻子，我个人很庆幸在遇见他之前没有看过这部剧，也很庆幸自己等了这么久才来看，这样我就永远不会感到困惑，也永远不会把这两者混为一谈。
I know who Josh is and I know who Ted is and now I feel like I just get to love them both.
我知道乔斯是谁，我也知道泰德是谁，现在我觉得我终于可以同时爱着他们两个了。
Yeah.
是的。
That's the best.
那是最棒的。
How does that feel Josh?
感觉怎么样，乔什？
That's the best, that's the podcast, right?
那是最棒的，这才是播客，对吧？
That's the, this came from that, right?
这就是，这个就是由此而来的，对吧？
This podcast that we're doing came from that in some way.
我们现在做的这个播客，在某种程度上就是从那来的。
Did it not?
难道不是吗？
Isn't that, that's the spark in some ways?
难道那不是，在某种程度上那就是火花吗？
Yeah.
对。
Yeah, she said, I want to watch it.
对，她说，我想看。
I'm ready to watch it.
我准备好看它了。
And so then I thought, you know, I called you, I said, you want to do something more formal because I'm going to start watching the show with Jordana.
然后我就想，你知道的，我给你打了电话，我说，你想做点更正式的节目吗，因为我要开始和乔丹娜一起看这部剧了。
I think I had listened to that voice note, but I was very moved just now and, you know, I really, I think I'm getting to see my, you know, I think a real love is you get to see yourself through someone else's eyes, through someone else's very loving eyes, you get to feel yourself worthy of that kind of love and I think that getting to watch the show with her and her being so clear on the boundaries and borders of my identity and who I am and who she met and who she fell in love with and who she's with now but also that he had this big life before her and this big very public facing aspect to that life.
我想我听过那条语音留言，但我刚才真的很感动，你知道的，我真的觉得，我觉得我开始通过别人的眼睛，通过别人充满爱意的眼睛来审视自己，你知道的，通过这种非常有爱的目光，你开始觉得自己配得上那种爱，我觉得和她一起看这部剧，而她对我的身份和边界、我是谁、她遇到的是谁、她爱上的是谁以及她现在和谁在一起有着如此清晰的认识，但同时也意识到他在她之前有过丰富的生活，而且那段生活有着非常公开的一面。
And just the ability to, yeah, to sit with her and show her, this is what I was doing.
仅仅是能够，是的，和她坐在一起并向她展示，这就是我过去所做的事情。
This is what helped me become the kind of man who could marry you and be here with you on this couch in Brooklyn watching this show.
这就是帮助我成为那种能够娶你并和你一起坐在布鲁克林的这张沙发上看这部剧的男人的经历。
It's very sweet and she, as you can hear, I guess I also really want to thank Jordana one for wanting to watch the show again, wanting to learn about this part of me.
这非常甜蜜，而且正如你所听到的，我想我也真的很想感谢乔丹娜，一是因为她想再次观看这部剧，想了解我生命中的这一部分。
And also, for her contributions week to week, I think they've really elevated the show.
二是因为她每周的贡献，我认为它们真的提升了这部剧的品质。
I think they've invited us, me, you and Craig and Alec, to go deeper in thinking about the show.
我认为他们邀请了我们——我、你、克雷格和亚历克，去更深入地思考这部剧。
I think she comes at this from such a pure, but really informed and thoughtful place.
我觉得她带着一种如此纯粹，但又真正见多识广且体贴入微的态度来看待这一切。
I love that my wife is both psychological and spiritual.
我爱我的妻子，她既感性又富有灵性。
She has these two qualities that were very important for me in partnership because I have those in myself.
她拥有这两种特质，这对我建立伴侣关系非常重要，因为我身上也有这些。
So it's been a real treat to both watch the show next to her and also hear her reflections on them.
所以，既能坐在她身旁看剧，又能听到她对剧集的感想，真是一种极大的享受。
She goes into our office and I think thinks for a little while and records these for us.
她走进我们的办公室，我想思考了一会儿，然后为我们录下了这些。
But it's been a real asset to the show to have her.
但有她在，确实是这部剧的一大财富。
She doesn't, she would die if we ever had her on as a guest.
她才不要——如果我们邀请她作为嘉宾上节目，她会当场社死。
She would freeze up and she doesn't like to be put on the spot, but she really likes to contribute in this particular way.
她会紧张得不知所措，她不喜欢被当成焦点，但她真的很喜欢用这种特殊的方式做出贡献。
So it's been, it's been just lovely.
所以这一切，这一切真的太美妙了。
So thanks, thank you, Jordana, for, for upping the quality of this show so considerably.
所以谢谢，谢谢你，乔丹娜，大幅提升了这档节目的质量。
And I love you.
我爱你。
As, as we're heading towards the end of this, Josh, I want to ask you a question about this whole venture that you have set us on here, this, these, these podcasts.
随着，随着我们要结束这一切，乔什，我想问你一个关于你让我们踏上的这段旅程、关于这些播客的问题。
I went back and I listened to the trailer, which we took much of from our very first and second episodes.
我回去听了预告片，我们的大部分预告片都截取自我们的第一集和第二集。
And the last line of the trailer is you saying, it's like, are you ready to go back to Titanic?
而预告片的最后一台词是你说的，就像是，你准备好回到《泰坦尼克号》了吗？
And I am as a huge Titanic fan who, yes, saw it twice on opening day.
而作为一个坚定的《泰坦尼克号》粉丝，我确实在首映当天看了两遍。
And yesterday, went to see the virtual reality experience here in Los Angeles.
昨天，我去了洛杉矶参观这里的虚拟现实体验。
I'm reminded, of course, that at the end, I know, holds for a plus.
当然，这让我想到，在结尾，我知道，稍等一下。
At the end of Titanic, I'm reminded that he didn't find what he was looking for, or more importantly, what he says is, I never let it in, right?
在《泰坦尼克号》的结尾，这让我想到他并没有找到他一直在寻找的东西，或者更重要的是，他说的是，我从未真正敞开心扉，对吧？
He discovered something new when he finally went back to Titanic.
当他最终回到泰坦尼克号时，他发现了新的东西。
So my question to you, Josh, is, is there something new that you never expected rewatching all of this and talking about it that it would do for you, or even more titanically, is there something that you're letting in?
所以我的问题是，乔什，有没有什么是你从未预料到的，在重新观看这一切并谈论它时，它会对你产生的影响，或者更像泰坦尼克号那样，有没有什么是你正在试着敞开心扉接受的？
Is there something that you've let in that maybe you haven't over the last decade or 20 years that doing this has done for you?
有没有什么是你现在敞开心扉去接受，但在过去十年或二十年里你可能没有接受过的，而做这件事为你带来了改变？
Yeah, what a great question, Alec.
是的，真是个好问题，亚历克。
I think that I've mentioned this before, but it bears repeating.
我想我以前提到过这一点，但值得重申。
I have always had a conflicted relationship with this show insofar as it gave me so much it also took away something that I didn't know I had and was precious.
我对这部剧一直有着矛盾的感情，因为它给予了我那么多，却也夺走了一些我甚至不知道自己拥有且弥足珍贵的东西。
My anonymity, my ability to be thought of as a singular, unified personality, Josh Radner, it bifurcated that and split that up in certain ways that were unsettling.
我的匿名性，我作为一个单一、统一的个体——乔什·拉德诺——被看待的能力，它将这一切对立并以某些令人不安的方式分裂了。
It gave me an identity crisis over the years that was hard to navigate.
多年来，这给了我一场很难应付的身份危机。
And it gave me, it was my patron, it allowed me to live a creative life and do all these different things and explore these different parts of myself and travel and expand my world in so many ways.
它给予了我，它就像我的资助人，让我能够过上一种富有创造力的生活，做所有这些不同的事情，探索我自己的不同部分，去旅行并在很多方面拓展我的世界。
It also, one of my favorite things is if I reach out to someone that I love their work or if I just admire them, whether it's show business or not, but my reputation precedes me a little bit.
而且，我最喜欢的一点是，如果我联系一个我喜欢其作品的人，或者如果我只是钦佩他们，无论是在演艺界还是其他领域，我的名声都会先我一步。
And people generally say, thanks for reaching out, let's have coffee.
人们通常会说，谢谢你联系我，我们喝杯咖啡吧。
So it allows me to be in the world in a pretty dynamic way that I've always really loved, but there's always been this shadow side to it.
因此，它让我以一种非常充满活力的方式融入这个世界，我一直真的很喜欢这一点，但它也一直伴随着阴暗面。
And it's always been this thing that I kind of was swatting away.
这总是我试图挥之不去的东西。
If someone came up to me and called me by my real name, I was so much friendlier than if they called me Ted.
如果有人走到我面前叫我的真名，我会比他们叫我泰德时友好得多。
or if they shouted Ted from their car, I would bristle and I would be angry about it.
或者如果他们从车里冲我大喊泰德，我会感到恼火并对此生气的。
But I've done a lot of work around it and I was doing a lot of really good work around that before we even did this show.
但我为此做了很多努力，甚至在我们做这个节目之前，我就已经在这方面做了很多非常好的努力。
Getting married helped me a lot with it just because my wife is a psychologist and she was so acutely and beautifully sensitive to this particular kind of sensitivity that I had around this.
结婚对这方面帮了我很大忙，仅仅因为我的妻子是一名心理学家，她对我有这种特殊的情绪敏感有着异常敏锐而美好的感知。
So I was moving through it and past it and integrating it more and more, but the process of revisiting the show and watching the show, I think I was able to, you know, we talked about this on a commercial, but I was just in Ecuador last weekend or the weekend before for a Comic Con.
所以我一直在经历它、超越它，并越来越多地将它整合起来，但重新审视这部剧和观看这部剧的过程，我想我能够，你知道的，我们曾在广告中谈到过这个，但我上周末或上上周末为了一个动漫展刚去过厄瓜多尔。
I was there for three or four days and I met a ton of people all from Ecuador and they were so lovely and so such beautiful people and they were so excited to see me and meet me.
我在那里呆了三四天，遇到了大量来自厄瓜多尔的人，他们都非常可爱，是非常好的人，他们看到我并见到我都超级兴奋。
And it wasn't all just about the show, they seemed to really see me in a kind of 360 way.
而且这并不全是关于这部剧，他们似乎真的以一种全方位的方式看到了我。
But meeting people who just said, you know, I love you so much.
但遇到那些只是说，你知道的，我太爱你了。
You taught me so much about life.
你教会了我很多关于生活的道理。
You inspire me.
你激励了我。
I don't know what my life would be without Ted Mosby in this show.
我不知道如果没有泰德·莫斯比和这部剧，我的生活会变成什么样的人。
Like I could hear it with different ears.
就像我能用不同的耳朵去倾听这些声音。
I could hear it with, I could hear it that they weren't saying you're just this one thing.
我能听到，我能听出他们并不是在说你只是这单一的东西。
They were saying, you changed my life.
他们是在说，你改变了我的生活。
you were a part of and the energy you brought to it changed my life.
你曾是其中的一部分，你带给它的能量改变了我的生活。
And that to me has been, I'm so glad that my ears are open enough and my heart is now open enough to hear that.
对我来说，这已经——我太高兴我的耳朵足够敞开，我的心现在也足够敞开去倾听这些了。
And you know, we talked about this, Craig, I remember we were saying like, sometimes people when they're such big fans of the show and they come up to you about the show, it almost feels like hostile or aggressive like, like they're being a little like me or it's tinged with some kind of edge.
你知道的，我们谈到过这个，克雷格，我记得我们当时说，有时当人们是这部剧的超级粉丝，他们为这部剧的事来找你时，感觉几乎带有敌意或侵略性，就像他们有点针对我，或者带有一种尖锐的边缘。
And I felt that for years, but now I'm just seeing the sweetness of it.
我多年来都有这种感觉，但现在我只看到了它可爱的一面。
And I'm seeing, you know, when a 14 or 15 year old comes up to me and I'm like, you weren't born when this show started, but you love it and it's teaching you something.
我看到，你知道的，当一个14或15岁的孩子走到我面前，而我想，这部剧开始时你还没出生呢，但你喜欢它，它正在教给你一些东西。
And I think that even though we're doing some Mia Culpas around some stuff we did, I think 85% of this show is like, we stand by it and we believe that we were imparting something beautiful.
而且我认为，尽管我们对过去做过的一些事进行了自我反省（Mea Culpa），但我认为这部剧85%的内容是——我们坚信不疑，我们相信我们是在传达某种美好的东西。
We are putting something beautiful into the culture.
我们正在向文化中注入美好的事物。
And it remains.
而它依然存在。
And I feel really grateful to have been a part of something like that.
能够成为这样一件事的一部分，我感到非常感激。
Some of those tender spots still remain.
其中一些敏感的痛点依然存在。
If you see me on the street, you'll have a much nicer encounter with me if you call me Josh.
如果你在街上看到我，如果你叫我乔什，你将会与我有一段更美好的偶遇。
You just will.
你真的会的。
I still have some sensitivities towards like, call me by my real name.
我对于像“用真名叫我”这样的事仍然有一些敏感。
But largely, I'm just able to understand why people love this show so much.
但总的来说，我能够理解为什么人们如此热爱这部剧。
And I'm getting to be, I think I've mentioned this, but Paul McCartney said, you know, when people come up to him and say, I'm such a fan of The Beatles and he says, oh, me too, you know, he was both a part of The Beatles and a huge driving force of why it was so brilliant and successful.
而且我正在变得，我想我提到过这一点，但保罗·麦卡特尼曾说，你知道的，当人们走到他面前说，我是披头士的超级粉丝时，他说，哦，我也是，你知道的，他既是披头士乐队的一部分，也是它如此辉煌和成功的一个巨大推动力。
And also he can hover outside it now and go, wow, this was a phenomenon.
同时他现在也可以置身事外地说，哇，这是一个现象级的事物。
We were carried aloft by something much bigger than just me and my own talent, my own song writing ability.
我们被某种远比我和我自己的才华、我自己的歌曲创作能力更伟大的东西所承载。
This was bigger than me.
这比我更伟大。
I'm a fan of the thing that I was a part of, which is a very strange thing to say, I'm a fan of this thing I was a part of, you know?
我是我曾参与其中的事物的粉丝，说出“我是我曾参与其中的事物的粉丝”这句话感觉非常奇怪，你知道吗？
If I suspect if I wasn't on how I met your mother, I would have really, really loved it.
我想如果我没有出演《老爸老妈浪漫史》，我真的会非常非常喜欢它。
I was actually thinking about this, Craig.
我其实一直在思考这件事，克雷格。
I was thinking, what are the chances of meeting two guys who were mostly my age, who both went to, we all went to small liberal arts colleges.
我在想，遇到两个和我差不多年龄、都去过——我们都去了小型文理学院的家伙，几率有多大？
One of them was from Ohio, where I was from.
其中一个来自俄亥俄州，也就是我来自的地方。
We have the same taste in music, the same taste in movies, the same kind of concerns in the world.
我们有着相同的音乐品味，相同的电影品味，对世界上有相同类型的关注。
We both wanted, we all want our lives to be magic and creative and funny and deep and philosophical.
我们都希望，我们都希望我们的生活是神奇的、有创意的、有趣的、深刻的和富有哲理的。
We want to interrogate what we're doing here.
我们想探究我们在这里究竟在做什么。
And what are the odds that you guys were creating a TV show at just the moment that I was the right age for it?
而你们在我正适合这个年龄的时刻创作了一部电视剧，几率又是多大？
I was the right look for it.
我有着适合它的外表。
I was the right.
我有着适合的。
I mean, this is why so much of, you know, life, they say, is, you know, luck meeting preparation, but like, what a stroke of good fortune that we all found each other when we did, and that we shared a sensibility, and we shared so much that we could really speak shorthand.
我的意思是，这就是为什么生活中的很多事情，人们常说，是运气遇到了准备，但是，我们能在那个时间点相遇，并且拥有共同的审美品味，分享了如此多以至于我们可以心领神会，这是多大的好运气啊。
I mean, I never, I never came up to you with a script, and I was like, I don't get it.
我的意思是，我从来没有，我从来没有拿着剧本走到你面前然后说，我不懂。
You know, like I understood what you guys were writing.
你知道的，就像我理解你们写的东西一样。
You know, I really understood it in some sort of cellular way, But I'm just, I'm so glad that I'm able to revisit this show with older, wiser, more forgiving eyes and ears and heart and say like, we did good, we did a good thing and I'm grateful to be a part of it.
你知道的，我从某种细胞层面上真正理解了它，但我只是，我太高兴我能够以更成熟、更明智、更宽容的眼光、耳朵和心灵来重新审视这部剧，并说，我们做得很好，我们做了一件好事，我很感激能成为其中一部分。
Beautifully said, I feel the same way.
说得太好了，我也是这么觉得的。
I feel the same way.
我有同感。
And one of the things I've gotten out of doing this podcast is just it's really solidified my sense of, this show belongs to the fans now and to the world.
做这个播客让我获得的一点感悟是，它真的巩固了我的这种感觉：这部剧现在属于粉丝，属于全世界。
It used to feel like so possessively ours, like every little part of it was us and reflected on us.
过去它感觉像是我们独占的私有财产，它的每一个小部分都是我们，并映射着我们。
Did we do it?
是我们做到的吗？
Right?
对吧？
Do we do not?
我们不是吗？
Right?
对吧？
There's just a softening and a release and a surrender of it in revisiting it like this.
以这种方式重新审视它，只是有一种软化、释放和顺其自然的感觉。
I'm so grateful it was received by the world.
我非常感激它能被世界所接受。
I feel like it's for the fans of this show.
我觉得这是献给这部剧的粉丝们的。
That's why we wrote it and that's what it's become and that's what it always should have been.
这就是我们创作它的原因，这也是它现在的样子，这也是它本来就应该有的样子。
I think when you're making it, it's harder to fully understand that and now I get it.
我想当你身在其中时，很难完全理解这一点，但现在我明白了。
It is that.
事实确实如此。
I just want to say thank you to the fans.
我只想对粉丝们说声谢谢。
Like that whole story I told about getting questioned at the end of season one, where we tell them the story the right way.
就像我讲过的那个关于在第一季结束时受到质疑的故事，我们用正确的方式把故事讲给他们听。
Thank you, everyone out there who found and supported this show and liked what we liked about the show.
谢谢大家，谢谢所有发现、支持这部剧并喜欢我们所喜欢的这部剧的人。
And you validated the kind of leap of faith pun intended for a future episode of Hymium.
你们验证了那种信仰之跃（双关语意，献给《老爸老妈浪漫史》的未来剧集）。
But leap of faith, we took to keep telling the story the way we did in season two, even after getting thrown, some doubt thrown at us about that.
但我们确实凭借信仰之跃，在第二季中继续以那种方式讲述故事，尽管当时有人对我们产生了一些怀疑。
The ending of the season of season one is one of my favorite things in the series It spun us into what I think is a great season two and just thanks.
第一季的结局是我在这部剧中最喜欢的部分之一，它把我们带入了我认为非常棒的第二季，谢谢大家。
Thanks to the fans who found this who got this who supported it and Pro proved proved us right to stick with our guns and keep telling the story the way we have Thank you to Carter base.
谢谢发现这部剧、理解这部剧、支持这部剧并证明我们坚持自我、继续用这种方式讲故事是正确的粉丝们。谢谢卡特·贝斯。
Thanks to everybody who worked on the show Josh What a pleasure to revisit it with you.
谢谢所有为这部剧付出努力的人。乔什，和你一起重温它真是太愉快了。
Thank you for having this idea to go back And it's a great way to bring on some of the other wonderful collaborative is like Carter and Pam and Ashley and Kobe and we'll have more in season two.
谢谢你提出回顾的想法，这真是个好方法，能把卡特、帕姆、阿什利和科比等其他优秀的合作者请来，我们在第二季还会有更多这样的安排。
It's been a joy and it really the show looks different through 20 years older eyes, but I'm loving it.
这是一段快乐的时光，用年长了20岁的双眼来看这部剧，感觉确实不同了，但我很喜欢。
I'm loving watching it again as future Craig with future Josh.
作为未来的克雷格和未来的乔什，我喜欢再次观看它。
So we've come to the final chapter of the final episode of season one of how we made your mother.
所以，我们来到了《老爸老妈浪漫史》第一季最后一集的最后一章。
We are delighted.
我们很高兴。
We have had so much fun.
我们度过了一段非常有趣的时光。
loved hearing from everyone we've loved strolling through season one with you all.
我们喜欢听取大家的意见，喜欢和大家一起漫步在第一季的回忆中。
Thank you so much for tuning in, for letting friends and family know about this, for sending in your letters and your voice notes.
非常感谢大家收听，感谢大家告诉身边的朋友和家人，感谢大家寄来信件和语音便签。
And we're just, we're having a great time.
而且我们，我们正过得很开心。
We'll be back.
我们会回来的。
We're not stopping.
我们不会停下。
We're going to carry on to season two.
我们将继续拍摄第二季。
Alec, what's happening?
亚历克，怎么说？
What's season two going to look like?
第二季会是什么样的？
It's going to be bigger and better than ever right here.
它会比以往任何时候都更大、更好，就在这里。
It's getting bigger and better than ever.
它正在变得比以往任何时候都宏大、精彩。
I guess there's a couple things we can say now is you're not going to have to wait that long so very, very likely it's going to just be certainly during this calendar year so you're not going to have to wait that much longer a couple weeks weeks, couple of months, we will be hard at work on season two.
我想现在有几件事我们可以说，那就是你们不用等那么久了，很有可能，绝对会在今年这个日历年内推出，所以你们不用再等那么久了，几周，几个月，我们将全力投入第二季的工作。
There is something, guys, guys, what could we say?
有一件事，伙计们，伙计们，我们能说什么呢？
A new opportunity that's going to help make the season two even bigger and even better and very cool, exciting opportunity that we'll be able to talk about in a little bit, not yet.
一个新机会将有助于让第二季变得更大、更好，这是一个非常酷、令人兴奋的机会，我们过一会儿再聊，现在还不行。
Right?
对吧？
And hopefully sometime in the fall, season two will come and there'll be some cool stuff we can share with you but can't talk about yet.
希望在秋天某个时候，第二季会到来，我们会有一些很酷的东西可以和大家分享，但现在还不能说。
And so are our final letters of the year.
所以这是我们今年的最后一封信。
We're doing a medley of letters, yeah, so this will be me and Cragger both reading these.
我们要搞一个信件串烧，是的，所以接下来我和克拉格都会朗读这些信件。
Thank you again so much for sending these in.
再次非常感谢大家寄来这些信。
They've been just incredibly moving to read and illuminating.
读到它们真的非常感人，也很有启发。
We learn new stuff about the show every single week, so thank you.
我们每周都能学到关于这部剧的新东西，所以谢谢你们。
The first letter, this is from Joe, there's a future version of you to whom this all makes more sense.
第一封信，来自乔：“有一个未来的你，对这一切会有更深刻的理解。”
immaculately sums up what I always found so comforting about him.
完美地总结了我一直觉得他最让人安心的地方。
It reminded me that no matter how lost and confused I felt, I would inevitably make it to the other side where I would then look back and see how those times of pain served a greater purpose in my life.
它提醒我，无论我感到多么迷茫和困惑，我最终都会到达彼岸，然后回过头去，看到那些痛苦的时刻是如何在我的生活中发挥更重大的作用的。
This is from Brittany M749, I like that we're calling these letters, they're like comments on things like they wrote us a letter, let me open up this piece of paper.
这封来自布里特妮M749，我喜欢我们把这些叫做信件，它们就像是对事情的评论，就像他们给我们写了一封信，让我打开这张纸。
Yeah, there.
对，就在那儿。
So this is a comment from Britney.
所以这是布里特妮的一条评论。
I was going to watch episode by episode with the weekly podcast.
我本来打算随着每周的播客一集一集地看。
I accidentally watched the entire series.
我一不小心把整个系列都看完了。
I love it.
我很喜欢。
Look, more power to you.
听着，随你便。
I've heard that a lot from people and I love it.
我从很多人那里听到过这种说法，我很喜欢。
My son, I'm watching it with my son for the first time, and he's way ahead already.
我的儿子，我正和儿子一起第一次看这部剧，他已经领先很多了。
He's just blazed one in his middle season too.
他已经在第二季中期突飞猛进了。
And I'm trying not to do that because I kind of want to watch them fresh each time.
而我尽量不那样做，因为我希望每次看都是新鲜的。
But I love it.
但我很喜欢。
If I wasn't demanding that Jordana watch it weekly with me, she would have, she'd be done with the show by now.
如果不是我要求乔安娜每周和我一起看，她早就看完了。
so I understand the impulse.
所以我理解这种冲动。
This is from Millie.
这封来自米莉。
I think ultimately what made my favorite show tied with Mad Men was that you dared to be storytellers, to play with chronology and subjectivity.
我认为最终让这部剧成为我最喜爱作品（与《广告狂人》并列）的原因是，你们敢于成为讲故事的人，敢于玩转时间和主观性。
You dared to make us pay attention, to make us think.
你们敢于让我们保持专注，让我们思考。
You dared to make us sit in the uncomfortable emotions that come with life.
你们敢于让我们去体验生活中那些令人不舒服的情绪。
This sitcom had a heartbeat and not just the formulaic pace of of comedy.
这部情景喜剧有心跳，而不仅仅是喜剧那种公式化的节奏。
Love that.
太棒了。
This is from at dive lost mind.
这封来自@dive lost mind。
I would I would just like to acknowledge the level of meta to this podcast.
我只想对这个播客的套娃层级表示赞赏。
The real life Josh Wagner at 50 years old looking back on a show about older Ted looking back on a younger Ted and adding commentary and hindsight to these past memories of working on the show and all the misadventures.
现实生活中的乔什·拉德纳在50岁时回顾一部关于年长的特德回顾年轻的特德的剧集，并为这些过去参与拍摄和各种奇遇的回忆添加评论和后见之明。
It's the most Tynium is single of all time.
这是史上最有“老爸老妈浪漫史”风格的事情。
It's true.
确实如此。
That's fantastic.
太棒了。
We have to make a poster blurb of that one.
我们得把那句做成海报宣传语。
Yeah.
对。
This is from Georgie Mee-Vili, 581.
这封来自乔治·米-维利，581。
I literally learned English language watching this TV show when I was a teenager.
我青少年时期就是看这部电视剧学的英语。
Now I'm living in Canada and when people are asking me how I learned the language so fast, I always answer watching himium.
现在我住在加拿大，当人们问我怎么学英语这么快时，我总是回答：看《老爸老妈浪漫史》。
No one believes me, but it's the absolute truth.
没有人相信我，但这绝对是实话。
That blows my mind every time I hear that.
每次听到这个，我都震惊了。
it's amazing.
这太惊人了。
This is from Julie Nelson 8196.
这封来自朱莉·纳尔逊8196。
I just want y'all to know that I've watched every episode of this beautiful podcast multiple times and the salute general questions, general questions, episodes as well.
我只想让你们知道，这个美丽的播客的每一集我都看了好几遍，还有那些向将军致敬的问题、将军的问题那一集也是。
I joined the Facebook group, Facebook group also.
我也加入了Facebook群组。
And of course I'm rewatching him on the daily.
当然，我每天都在重温这部剧。
This has just been such a joy.
这真的是太开心了。
I adore this podcast, especially because I work the night shift and I'm always awake when the episodes drop, which what Alex, is that like three in the morning on Sunday night into Monday, Monday morning, I should say, is it on the east coast three o'clock, midnight on California?
我非常喜欢这个播客，特别是由于我上夜班，当新节目发布时我总是醒着的，亚历克，那是周日晚上到周一早上的三点钟左右吗？应该说是周一早上，在东部时间是三点吗，加利福尼亚是半夜？
It's fantastic.
太棒了。
I've heard this from a bunch of people that they worked the night shift and put it right on at three in the morning.
我从很多人那里听说他们上夜班，并在凌晨三点准时收听。
I love that, that's wonderful.
我很喜欢，这太棒了。
I love keeping people company on the night shift.
我喜欢在夜班陪伴大家。
This is from Kira Johnson.
这封来自基拉·约翰逊。
This is my first time watching the podcast instead of listening and I have never seen Craig and Alec before.
这是我第一次看播客视频而不是听音频，我以前从没见过克雷格和亚历克。
It's so weird.
太诡异了。
They are not what I thought they would look like.
他们长得跟我想象的完全不一样。
I so need there to be more after that, even if it's an insult, it's the wonder, it's the wondering if it's an insult that is so gutted there.
我太需要后面还有更多内容了，哪怕那是句侮辱，那种猜测它是不是侮辱的心情才真的是让人抓狂。
It depends on your mood of the day, how you're taking that.
这取决于你当下的心情，你是怎么看待这句话的。
You're either thinking, she thinks we're much better looking than she thought, or she's shocked by what she says to her.
你要么觉得，她觉得我们比想象中帅得多，要么就是被她的言论震惊到了。
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
Like, the rest of it probably isn't like just how much like Brad Pitt we look, it's that's It's probably not the sentence that got chuffed off there, but thanks question mark, can you read Johnson's 3.029 or how dare you 5050?
就像，剩下的部分可能不是在夸我们长得有多像布拉德·皮特，可能不是那句话被掐掉了，不过谢谢打问号，你能读一下约翰逊的3.029或者“你怎么敢”5050吗？
Okay, this is from Cassandra, Josh, I am so truly proud of you and so happy for you that you have finally reached a place that you could do this.
好吧，这封来自卡珊德拉，乔什，我真的为你感到骄傲，也为你终于达到了能够做到这一步的境界感到高兴。
I know it took you a long time to come back around to this character that was immensely beloved by so many.
我知道，你花了很长时间才重新接受这个深受许多人喜爱的角色。
Hemium has truly been my escape for years.
多年来，Hemium 真的成为了我的避风港。
Even to this day, I still re-watch my favorite episodes.
直到今天，我仍然会反复观看我最喜欢的剧集。
It's become a comfort to me.
它已经成了我的精神慰藉。
I truly thank you for your many years on the show and I really appreciate you doing this, not only for yourself, but for the fans.
我真心感谢你多年来对这部剧的付出，也非常感激你做这一切，不仅是为了你自己，也是为了粉丝们。
I hope this brings you more healing and peace.
我希望这能带给你更多的治愈和平静。
Thanks, Cassandra, that's so lovely.
谢谢你，卡珊德拉，太暖心了。
That's meant to have been Kira Johnson's thing about it.
这本来应该是基拉·约翰逊想说的话。
I don't care, right?
我不在乎，对吧？
Sorry, Kira, Kira, you can follow up, but we don't know, you got to, you left us hanging, here we go.
抱歉，基拉，基拉，你可以接着说，但我们不知道，你得，你把我们晾在这了，开始吧。
We're going to open season two with a further explanation from Kira.
我们将在第二季开篇时由基拉做进一步的解释。
The reveal, once the missing sentence there.
揭秘，曾经缺失的那句话。
David Anthony writes, I think it is also so loved because they captured a moment before two major changes, major changes, major changes.
大卫·安东尼写道，我认为它之所以如此受欢迎，是因为它捕捉到了两个重大变革发生前的那个时刻，重大变革，重大变革。
One is the sort of preceding the death of cable TV and sitcoms about young 20 something's figuring it out as things transition to streaming and overly dramatic bingeable TV.
一是它发生在有线电视消亡以及关于二十多岁年轻人摸索生活的处境喜剧转型为流媒体和过度戏剧化、适合一口气刷完的电视剧之前。
The second is that it captures life in the sweet spot of the internet.
第二个是它捕捉到了互联网处于黄金时期的生活。
It was there and used, but it was not our entire life.
它就在那里，也被使用着，但它并不是我们生活的全部。
We go on it and and then got off it.
我们会上去，然后下来。
And we still interacted with each other in real life and made plans.
我们仍然在现实生活中互相交往并制定计划。
So it's not just the romance of the show, but the romance of a time before these inventions changed who we are and how we live.
所以，这不仅是对节目的浪漫化，更是对这些发明改变我们是谁以及我们如何生活之前的那个时代的浪漫化。
I think that is brilliant.
我觉得这太绝了。
I haven't really thought about that, but that is such a great insight.
我之前真没这么想过，但这真是一个极好的见解。
Thank you for that, David.
谢谢你，大卫。
Yeah, it's there, but it's not everything.
是的，它就在那儿，但它不是全部。
I love that.
我很喜欢这个观点。
Thank you, David, brilliant.
谢谢你，大卫，太精彩了。
Sanjay says, like Marshall talks to Stella about Ted's relationship with Star Wars, and how he watches the movies when he's happy, sick, et cetera.
桑杰说，就像马歇尔跟斯特拉谈论特德与《星球大战》的关系一样，他会在开心、生病等时候看这些电影。
The same is for me with how I met your mother.
我对《老爸老妈浪漫史》也是这种感觉。
I lost count of how many times I watched the series from beginning to end.
我已经数不清自己从头到尾看了多少遍这部剧了。
There are days that I'm in a special mood and I watch a very specific episode.
有时我心情特殊，就会去看某一集非常特定的剧集。
This show helped me in my worst times, kept me company during my sleepless nights, made me laugh and cry uncontrollably many, many times since I bumped into it by accident on TV back in 2008.
自从2008年在电视上偶然看到它以来，这部剧在我最艰难的时刻帮助了我，在我失眠的夜晚陪伴着我，让我无数次开怀大笑、痛哭流涕。
And the final letter from Hello Leesh.
最后一位是来自 Hello Leesh 的信。
I so appreciate when you guys recognize that this show belongs to the fans, perhaps more than it belongs to those who created it.
我很感激你们能认识到，这部剧属于粉丝，或许比属于它的创作者还要多。
It took me a while to recognize that this is the case.
我花了很长时间才意识到这一点。老实说，
In all honesty, I've been frustrated when an actor doesn't remember one of their iconic lines when asked in an interview, or when one of the show's writers gives an opinion about one of the characters that defies all the analysis I've done of that character for decades.
以前当一个演员在采访中被问及某个标志性台词却想不起来时，或者当剧中的某个编剧对某个角色的看法完全颠覆了我几十年来对该角色的所有分析时，我会感到沮丧。
And then I realize this belongs to the fans.
然后我意识到，这是属于粉丝的。
No one has watched and analyzed these stories as much as the fans have.
没有人像粉丝那样观看和分析过这些故事。
It's the fans that are the keepers of these stories, these characters and their souls.
正是粉丝们在守护着这些故事、这些角色以及他们的灵魂。
The soul of the show itself continues to live in the hearts and minds and lives of the people who love it dearly.
剧集本身的灵魂继续活在那些深爱它的人的心中、脑海中和生活中。
And just like an artist can put her love and care and spirit into creating a painting, if that painting is passed on to a new owner, it's quite likely the owner will come to love and know that painting, particularly from studying and appreciating it daily, more than the creator of said art.
就像艺术家可以将她的爱、关怀和精神倾注在创作一幅画作中一样，如果这幅画被转交给新主人，通过每天的研究和欣赏，新主人很可能会比这门艺术的创造者更爱并了解这幅画。
The spirit that went into that thing is amplified or diminished depending on how much the keeper loves appreciates it.
倾注其中的精神会被放大或减弱，这取决于守护者有多爱它、多感激它。
And the reason this show is so magical is because there is a band of keepers that continue to nourish the soul of this work of art.
这部剧之所以如此神奇，是因为有一群守护者在不断滋养这件艺术品的灵魂。
Thank you for not only creating it, but for passing it down to us.
感谢你们不仅创造了它，还把它传承给我们。
You may never know how much this means to so many people's lives.
你们可能永远不会知道这对许多人的生活意味着什么。
Well, we are getting to know it from letters like that.
嗯，我们正是通过这样的信件开始了解到的。
And I'm just humbled, Craig, to have to have been a part of something that means this much to people, and also to create it with someone I like so much.
克雷格，我感到非常荣幸，能成为对人们有如此重大意义的作品的一部分，而且还是和我很喜欢的人一起创作的。
I just love you, my friend.
我就是爱你，我的朋友。
And when I thought about who I wanna walk down memory lane with, you were the person that I wanted to do it with, you and I have always had a sweet and special connection.
当我想象着我想和谁一起重温旧梦时，你就是我最想一起合作的那个人，你和我之间一直有着一种甜蜜而特殊的连接。
I know that Ted was based on Carter, and I think it's funny that the guy who was playing the Carter felt this ease of friendship with you, who was the Marshall, because Ted and Marshall love each other, you know, and I love you always.
我知道特德是以卡特为原型的，我觉得很有趣的是，扮演卡特的那个家伙会觉得和你——也就是马歇尔——之间的友谊是如此轻松自然，因为特德和马歇尔互相深爱着对方，你知道的，我永远爱你。
And I'm grateful that we are getting to have this second life professionally together by revisiting this thing we made.
我很感激我们通过重新审视我们共同创作的作品，在职业生涯中迎来了这第二春。
And I just think you're the sweetest, specialist, funniest, kindest dude, and I'm just so grateful you're in my life.
我觉得你真的是最甜美、最特别、最有趣、最善良的伙计，我非常庆幸我的生命中有你。
Oh man, thanks Josh.
天哪，谢谢你，乔什。
I'm very moved by that, thanks buddy.
我对此非常感动，谢谢你，老兄。
I filled the exact same way about you.
我对你的感觉完全一样。
how lucky that you walked into Carter in my office in 2005 and were Ted Mosby and you were the guy and you became our dear, dear friend.
多么幸运，你在2005年走进卡特在我的办公室，成为了特德·莫斯比，你就是那个真命天子，并且成为了我们亲密无间的好朋友。
We loved you then.
我们那时就爱你。
We love you now.
我们现在依然爱你。
There's no show without you and getting to go back on this journey with you and celebrate our friendship and all the friendship we shared with everybody that created the show.
没有你，就没有这部剧，能够和你一起重走这段旅程，庆祝我们的友谊，以及我们与所有创作这部剧的人分享的所有友谊。
It's really special and I really need it right now.
这真的很特别，我现在的确很需要它。
I think I keep hearing from fans that say, I like this right now, I need this moment, I need this time travel, I need this little break from what the world feels like.
我想我一直听到粉丝们说，我现在就喜欢这样，我需要这个时刻，我需要这种时间旅行，我需要从现实世界的感受中得到一点喘息。
And it's really a gift to get that with you, Josh.
能和你有这样的经历，真的是一份厚礼，乔什。
So thank you for inviting me on that journey.
所以谢谢你邀请我踏上这段旅程。
And thanks to Gerdana too, because I really think it sparked from her in a lot of ways and sparked from your marriage and it sparked from where you are in your life right now.
也要感谢格尔达娜，因为我真的觉得这在很大程度上是由她引发的，由你们的婚姻引发的，也由你目前的生活状态引发的。
So thank you for letting me continue to be a part of your life, my friend.
所以谢谢你让我继续成为你生命的一部分，我的朋友。
I love you.
我爱你。
Love you too, brother.
我也爱你，兄弟。
Hey, Alec, we love you too, my friend.
嘿，亚历克，我们也爱你，我的朋友。
And I love you guys.
我也爱你们。
Thank you so much for- you don't look anything like I was picturing.
非常感谢-你长得跟我脑海中想象的一点也不一样。
We'll see you next season, everyone.
大家，我们下季见。
Thanks so much for going on this journey with us.
非常感谢大家和我们一起踏上这段旅程。
Thanks.
谢谢。
See you next season.
下季见。
How We Major Mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thompson.
《老爸老妈浪漫史》由乔什·拉德纳和克雷格·托马斯主持并担任执行制片人。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
本节目由我、亚历克·莱夫制作，我们的联合制作人是道格·马蒂卡。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios, and our digital content producer AKA Gen Z Master is Emily Blumberg.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的亚历克斯·里夫斯，我们的数字内容制作人兼 Z 世代大师是艾米莉·布伦贝格。
Artwork by John Morrow.
封面插图由约翰·莫罗绘制。
Please follow, rate and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在苹果播客或你选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论本节目。
It really does help the show.
这确实对节目很有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是《NYC》，由我们自己的乔什·拉德纳创作，克雷格·托马斯和安德鲁·马朱斯基提供额外音乐。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢萝拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajorMother.com to sign up for our Substack mailing list and for links to our social media.
访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 注册我们的 Substack 邮件列表，并获取我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
你也可以点击联系页面给我们发送电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
你的故事和问题是本节目的重要组成部分。
Want some merch?
想要一些周边吗？
Click on the store link or go to HowYouGetYourMerch.com.
点击商店链接或访问 HowYouGetYourMerch.com。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack, Order Craig Thomas's debut novel at CraigThomasWriter.com slash novel, and you could subscribe to my Dead Father's Society, also on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅乔什·拉德纳的 Muse Letters，在 CraigThomasWriter.com/novel 订购克雷格·托马斯的处女作小说，你也可以订阅我的 Dead Father's Society，同样在 Substack 上。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital heart disease research.
要了解如何为之做出贡献，本节目正在进行为先天性心脏病研究筹款的长期活动。
Check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”标签页。
This episode was made possible by the support of Backyard Ventures.
本集的播出得到了 Backyard Ventures 的支持。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞的。